“This is impossible!”
The SCP site director wasn’t normally a
calm or cheerful man, but the researcher had
rarely seen him as angry as he was right now.
His face turned a deep beet red as he scanned
the documents on his desk before he asked
how months of valuable research on this subject
had suddenly gone blank, the data was completely
gone.
The researcher gulped nervously, hoping a
demotion wasn’t in his future, and nodded.
How could this be possible.
This was an experienced researcher who should
have been taking all of the necessary precautions.
Could the being they were studying somehow
have erased all these documents himself?
That’s just what the researcher had been
trying to find out for months, with hours
and hours spent trying to learn the extent
of its abilities.
“Well?
Where are they?”
the site director asked.
“I want everything you have!”
The researcher dropped a print-out of their
research on the mysterious subject’s abilities
on the director’s desk.
Every relevant line read “Data Lost”.
The director let out a deep sigh.
He wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew, well everything he could remember at
least, from the beginning.
The researcher sat town and began to relay
everything he could about SCP-343, which some
of the other researchers had started to refer
to by the nickname…
God.
SCP-343 was first sighted in Prague, just
an unassuming older man wandering the streets.
He seemed completely normal to everyone who
passed him by - until he decided he was tired
of staying on the ground.
An SCP agent stationed in the area noticed
the old man disappear from the streets as
if he was blinking out of existence - only
to appear on a rooftop nearby.
The local SCP teams were marshalled, and they
had soon tracked down what seemed to be a
very powerful specimen.
But SCP-343 didn’t seem concerned.
He reacted calmly when detained by the foundation
and went with them willingly.
He was detained in a standard holding cell
for interrogation and examination, but he
seemed completely at ease with his sudden
confinement.
It would soon become clear that this ordinary
old man was anything but.
Doctors Beck and Ndlovu were brought in to
consult on the SCP’s classification, and
that’s when the first anomalies began.
Their assessments matched initially, but when
it came time to describe him physically, things
took a strange turn.
Older male, seemingly non-descript and with
no unusual physical features.
Caucasian in appearance.
Doctor Ndlovu was confused by what Doctor
Beck was describing in his report.
This man was clearly black.
The two doctors quarrelled, unable to square
their differing perceptions.
They decided to bring in a third impartial
view to settle it - their fellow researcher,
Dr. Wan.
She didn’t take long before coming back
with her assessment.
Older male, seemingly non-descript and with
no unusual physical features.
Asian in appearance, possibly Chinese.
Whatever SCP-343 was, he seemed to be perceived
by each staff member as close in appearance
to their own race.
But that was only the start of the anomalies
surrounding the old man in the holding cell.
Dr. Beck started making regular visits to
the mysterious man, and in their first interview,
he asked the old man who he was and how he
came by his abilities.
The old man had a simple response.
“I created this universe.”
Dr. Beck stifled a laugh and decided to indulge
the old man’s delusion.
It was a fascinating claim, but could he prove
it?
Without another word, SCP-343 got up from
his chair, laughed, and turned around and
walked through the solid wall in the holding
cell and disappeared.
Dr. Beck was about to hit the panic button
and marshall the facility’s security to
find him when the strange man reappeared,
walking through the solid wall.
The only thing that was different?
He was holding a hamburger, which he sat down
and enjoyed.
The facility quickly went on lockdown and
a full investigation was done into how SCP-343
breached containment.
But there was no evidence of any security
breach, no failures in containment, and no
evidence of any other cells failing.
SCP-343 hadn’t broken through the security
- he had just ignored it, as if it wasn’t
there at all.
When questioned about how he had gone on his
hamburger run, he simply repeated his belief
that he was God - in between bites of his
fast food treat.
This would be far from the only time strange
things happened around SCP-343.
SCP containment cells are as secure as they
need to be, but even the least-strict containment
isn’t known for its decor.
Which is why Dr. Beck was in for a surprise
the next time he paid a visit to SCP-343.
The bare-bones cell now looked like a comfortable
home, decorated in Old English fashions.
The scientists assumed that SCP-343 had been
making many more trips out of his cell to
get accessories to feel more at home - but
that didn’t explain all the changes to the
cell.
No one could explain how he had installed
a roaring fireplace in the containment cell
- and everyone who entered could swear the
cell looked many times bigger than any other
cell in the facility.
SCP-343 wasn’t just breaking containment
- he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility.
The rules of the SCP containment facility
didn’t seem to be a concern to SCP-343,
but there was one thing he didn’t seem to
want to do - escape.
After every sudden exit, he would always return
to his personal cell and treat it as his home.
When interviewed by staff members, he was
polite but vague, and everyone seemed to enjoy
talking to him.
It was decided to keep him on site, not attempt
to increase his security, but restrict access
and keep his room guarded at all times to
ensure only researchers with Level 3 access
and above were allowed to meet with him.
But God works in mysterious ways.
Minimal Security Site 17 was one of the less-restrictive
SCP containment sites, hosting anomalies that
could be safely contained and weren’t likely
to mount violent escapes.
But as in every SCP facility, security was
still taken seriously and only those with
proper clearance could interact with the subjects.
So why did SCP-343 seem impossible to guard?
While only Level 3 clearance and above were
allowed in, the guards assigned to protect
the entrance all seemed to fall down on the
job.
Security Officer James, who was supposed to
be keeping people out of SCP-343’s cell,
had instead let in multiple visitors in addition
to dropping in several times himself.
When questioned on why he had gone against
orders and done so, he simply replied that
343 seemed lonely and was so happy every time
he got company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do.
The security guard was reassigned and new
ones were brought in - but history repeated
itself.
Guards were given stricter instructions to
minimize exposure - but SCP-343’s presence
always seemed to influence them anyway.
His containment cell was a revolving door,
with staff members at the facility entering
regularly for friendly conversations.
Dr. Beck decided it was time to take matters
into his own hands.
He would meet with SCP-343 one-on-one and
express how dangerous these security breaches
were.
He would try to convince the mysterious being
that he needed to stop influencing the minds
of the guards watching him, or the facility
would have to look into new measures to contain
him.
Dr. Beck entered the containment cell and
had a long conversation with SCP-343, and
when he emerged...he had a big smile on his
face, like he had just finished a reunion
with an old friend.
He gave the current guard a friendly clap
on the back, and told him not to worry so
much about security.
After all, nothing bad was going to happen
from letting people at the facility visit
SCP-343, right?
He wasn’t dangerous in any way.
He also said that security should bring him
anything he requests so he would feel less
need to leave his cell.
Minimal Security Site 17 soon became a model
SCP facility, with morale being the highest
of any site - with most giving the credit
to the presence of SCP-343.
Employees generally make daily visits to his
chambers, and he seems to have an encyclopedic
knowledge of anything they want to talk about
- including things he should have no way of
knowing.
Guards no longer quit their posts or break
protocol, as their only real duty is to keep
track of who meets with SCP-343 so they can
be interviewed and debriefed after.
Everyone’s conversation is different, but
they all report being in a better mood after
leaving than when they came in.
No further information is available on SCP-343’s
origins, the full extent of his powers, or
whether he is telling the truth about being
the God who created the universe.
The site director rubbed his temples after
hearing the researcher’s explanation.
“So what you’re telling me is that we
have an uncontained, highly powerful SCP that
has not only been breaking containment whenever
it wants, but has managed to destroy all the
files regarding the research on it?”
The researcher’s answer was yes.
However, the situation at Site 17 seemed to
be stable, and they had come up with a plan
that should help to maximize the positive
effect SCP-343 has on the facility.
They were even hypothesizing that staff from
other sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343’s presence.
The site director wasn’t impressed though.
He wanted the researcher to go back to the
drawing board and redo the research.
After all, if all the files were blank, how
could they ever learn how to properly contain
it?
That’s what the C in SCP stood for after
all - containment.
The researcher finally had to stand up to
the director though, and told them that it
wasn’t a good idea.
That they had already tried everything to
contain SCP-343, but that it wasn’t that
he broke containment, it was as if he didn’t
even acknowledge that an attempt had been
made to contain him.
He was omnipotent, aware of things he shouldn’t,
and able to do things that broke the laws
of physics without breaking a sweat.
There was no evidence that this was God, the
creator of the universe as he claimed to be,
but there also wasn’t any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn’t.
The researcher’s best guess was that this
was a powerful reality bender whose abilities
knew no limits, and that the only reason he
was staying in the facility was because he
wanted to, and doing anything to change that
might cause him to change his benevolent ways.
The director sighed.
As much as he hated to admit it, his researcher
was making good points.
He wanted to meet SCP-343 personally.
But did he need to know anything first?
“Well, sir…” the researcher replied,
“he likes hamburgers.
But beyond that, he’ll take care of the
rest.
He’s right where we left him, in his home
- waiting for his next guest.”
Over fifty men and women, clad in red robes,
kneel before an unholy altar.
They chant and mutter indecipherable words
- words of cruelty and madness… of obsession
and sacrilege.
Not long ago, these were regular people.
Computer technicians, teachers, plumbers,
construction workers, accountants.
This was before they fell under the ungodly
influence of a new ruler.
The center of this makeshift place of worship
was once a normal school gymnasium, but it’s
now the home of a huge statue.
A humanoid being, wreathed in tentacles.
Its head is more like a squid or cuttlefish
than anything resembling an actual human face.
While he’s known to the cultists as the
Tentacled God, the beast they worship is known
to the SCP Foundation as SCP - 2662, and he
sits in the belly of one of their expansive
containment facilities, locked away from the
world.
But not for long, if his devoted followers
have anything to say about it.
This is their god, all-powerful and unchanging,
and when it comes to springing him from containment,
no tactic is too vile or underhanded to get
the job done.
Their mortal leader and high-priest, a man
in a purple robe calling himself Brother Marsh,
walks among their crouched forms.
He whispers instructions for the great day
of liberation that’s soon to come, providing
everyone plays their part.
It’s a plan months in the making - and one
that, if it goes off without a hitch, could
free their monstrous god into the world.
They would strike at the very heart of their
enemy, The SCP Foundation, when they least
expect it, and nothing shall stand in their
way.
How could they lose when they have a god on
their side?
But why did all these normal people become
violent zealots for squid-faced deity?
It all began with a dream.
To those who experienced these dreams, they
felt more like prophecies, premonitions of
the glorious horrors to come.
A red sky, billions dead and billions more
enslaved.
A dark silhouette on the horizon - Their Tentacled
God, holding dominion over all.
At first, it just seemed like a strange nightmare.
The ones who experienced it woke up shaken
and afraid, hoping to shake the images from
their mind.
But they couldn’t.
Every night, the nightmare would return.
They’d see the images - the red sky, the
dead and enslaved, the Tentacled God.
And after a while it would come to them even
when they weren’t asleep, eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes.
Little by little, this scene stopped looking
so hideous… and started to look glorious.
They felt his presence in their minds, slowly
pushing them towards their inevitable future.
They started to realize that they wanted him
to rule over the universe, and to experience
the honor of serving him.
Many of them abandoned their homes and families
- leaving their friends and loved ones left
to worry that they’d gone insane.
In their eyes, they were safer than they’d
ever been.
They finally had purpose.
They were working in service of something
far greater than themselves.
The influence of the tentacled god drew them
closer to one another.
They would meet in secret, exchanging information
from the prophecies their ruler sent them
in their dreams.
They worshipped together, building altars
and idols to congregate around.
They performed dark blood rituals, involving
human and animal sacrifice.
It was when Brother Marsh, The Anointed One,
arrived to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear.
Just three months prior, Brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data entry
for a large insurance company, before the
Tentacled God invaded his thoughts with a
simple message: “FREE ME, AND THE NEW WORLD
I CREATE SHALL BE YOUR PLAYGROUND.”
Since then, he’d devoted himself completely
to the cause, quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his new
life’s purpose - infiltrating the SCP Foundation,
and releasing his inhuman ruler from its imprisonment.
That was the single goal he united the cultists
under: Freedom for the Tentacled God.
And at long last, they had all the pieces
in place to strike.
They’d finally gathered the necessary intel
to subvert the will of the most powerful secret
organization on earth.
Even the strongest institution is made of
people, and people are weak.
Unlike the almighty Tentacled God, people
could be broken.
The people in question were Kelly Thompson,
Sidney Levitt, Jordan Brosh, Dr. Juan Gutierrez,
and Gillian Larson.
Dr. Juan Gutierrez was a researcher with Level
3 clearance on the site where the Tentacled
God was being contained.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both Security
Officers charged with verifying personnel
clearance on site.
Kelly Thompson was a member of Site Administration
with research authorization powers, and Gillian
Larson was a research assistant who often
collaborated with Dr. Gutierrez.
These five were the key to getting access
to SCP-2662 and bringing their plan to fruition.
Normally, personnel dossiers on people working
for the Foundation were highly confidential,
but the Devotees of the Tentacled God had
their ways.
They had a number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in and
pulling some basic information off of Foundation
servers without being detected.
For the other information they needed they
turned to some good, old-fashioned torture,
which is often the most effective method when
you need some quick results.
Of course, while the cult’s grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous, they weren’t
stupid.
While gathering their intel, they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were up
against.
SCP-2662 was being held in a humanoid containment
cell, and guarded by on-site Task Force TAU-9,
better known as the “Belligerent Bodyguards.”
These aren’t lazy, donut-chomping mall cops
- these are a heavily trained, heavily armed
fighting force.
Though the cultists had one thing that these
Foundation soldiers didn’t: The element
of surprise.
For everything to go off perfectly, Brother
Marsh’s plans would have to be executed
within a single day, and they were already
on the clock.
TAU-9 had been charged with tracking down
any new SCP - 2662 cults and dismantling them,
and Brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the Foundation tracked
them down and did the same to them.
If they wanted any chance of freeing the Tentacled
God, then they needed to strike quickly and
with overwhelming force.
The SCP-2662 worshippers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key Foundation personnel,
and station members outside each of them - including
one who could realistically imitate each.
They waited for night to fall, and broke into
each of their homes as they slept.
What followed was a sequence of ruthless and
efficient murders done in the cause of freeing
their god.
Dr. Gutierrez was shot in the head while he
slept.
Sidney Levitt and Jordan Brosh were both stabbed
to death before either even realized what
was happening.
Thompson, who’d gotten up to use the bathroom,
went down in a hail of machine gun fire.
Gillian Larson had seen that masked figures
were breaking into her home and attempted
to flee, but was caught and beaten to death
by cultists in her hallway.
It was a strange irony that people whose day
jobs entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies imaginable
were murdered in their homes by nothing more
than regular humans.
So far, Brother Marsh’s plan had gone perfectly,
with all five key personnel murdered within
a two minute period.
Next, the selected doppelgängers stole clothes
from their victims’ closets and were handed
the correct forged documentation.
The next morning, each replacement began their
journeys to the site where the Tentacled God
was being contained, while the rest of the
cult armed themselves in preparation for their
own part in the plan.
Nobody at the Foundation seemed to notice
anything amiss when the five arrived on site.
When you work for the SCP Foundation, more
mental energy is devoted to following the
rules that keep you alive than to memorizing
the faces of all your co-workers and each
one slipped neatly into position, disappearing
into the familiarity of office life.
But, infiltrating the site was one thing,
getting past the Belligerent Bodyguards and
into the cell of the Tentacled God would be
another thing entirely.
That’s where the rest of the cult would
come into play.
Heavily armed with whatever firearms they
could get their hands on, the rest of the
Devotees of the Tentacled God - Brother Marsh
included - would attack the containment site
head-on.
In the ensuing chaos, the five cultists who
had already infiltrated the site could take
advantage of the distraction, and break into
the containment chamber.
It was perfect.
They’d launch their attack from the outside…
and from within.
When Brother Marsh declared that the time
was right, the assault began.
A legion of gun-wielding cultists seemed to
spring out of nowhere and started shooting
up the warehouse that was a front for the
containment site.
The site quickly mobilized guards and task
force members to take on the sudden threat,
and just as Brother Marsh had anticipated,
the Site Director called on the majority of
TAU-9 to help repel the violent cultists from
their perimeter.
TAU-9 obeyed, leaving three task force members
behind to guard SCP - 2662’s containment
chamber.
They expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an audience
with their god.
What they didn’t expect was a group of five
Foundation employees walking right up to them
and opening fire, killing two TAU-9 members
and taking the third as a hostage.
While the war was being waged outside, the
infiltrators had found the Tentacled God’s
containment cell in the low-risk humanoid
ward.
Their hostage insisted that using him wouldn’t
give them any leverage - the rest of his team
would neutralize the whole group, him included,
if that’s what it took to stop them.
The infiltrators explained that using him
as leverage was never their intention - he
wasn’t a hostage at all.
He was a sacrifice.
The cultists of the Tentacled God detonated
explosives, creating a hole in the wall and
finally giving them access to their deity.
They climbed through and gazed upon him in
awe.
There stood SCP-2662, twice as tall as a regular
man, with ten huge tentacles emerging from
its back.
In their months of envisioning this creature,
they’d pictured it sitting on a throne made
of thousands of human bones, ready to dictate
its commands to the obedient liberators.
What they certainly didn’t expect was to
see the Tentacled God hunched over a computer
screen.
Still, gods work in mysterious ways, so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting.
They pulled out a sacrificial dagger, and
began sacrificing their captured TAU-9 member.
It was at this point that SCP - 2662 turned
and saw what they were doing with a look of
pure horror.
He rose up from his computer, his headphones
getting caught as he did so.
He told them to go away, that he didn’t
want them here, and that them murdering people
in his bedroom like this was inconsiderate
and disgusting.
The cultists became even more confused - why
wasn’t their god accepting their offerings?
What were they doing wrong?
They tried more chanting, and painting arcane
symbols on the floor in blood, but this just
seemed to make the creature angrier.
He told them, in a tone more fitting for a
teenage boy than a Lovecraftian God, to just
leave him alone so he could play his video
games.
This was seriously not cool!
The cultists were baffled.
They told the Tentacled God they were there
to free him.
He replied that he didn’t need saving.
That crazy stalkers like them were why he
turned himself in to the Foundation in the
first place!
Before the cultist infiltrators could get
another word in, the remaining members of
TAU-9 stormed into the containment cell and
gunned them down with surgical precision.
The war outside was already over - Brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were all
killed in the firefight.
TAU-9 didn’t look the least bit surprised
upon entering 2662’s cell, this was a common
occurrence unfortunately.
They had to deal with an attempted cult invasion
every few months, because SCP-2662’s main
anomalous ability is inspiring violent cults
who relentlessly track down and worship it
with arcane and bloodthirsty rituals.
The problem is, 2662 doesn’t do this consciously,
and definitely doesn’t like the results.
That’s why he’s under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him amused
with video games and reading material while
fending off the deranged cults who try to
invade and abduct him.
Following the termination of The Devotees
of the Tentacled God, just one of many cults
who’d broken into 2662’s containment cell,
the remaining TAU-9 members apologized to
the tentacled creature for the disturbance,
allowing him to return to his gaming.
They assured him that it’d probably be at
least a few more months before something like
this happened again.
SCP-2662’s cell was repaired, and the Foundation
returned to its task of seeking out would-be
cultist emancipators, because for the SCP
Foundation, it’s not always about the anomaly
that’s being kept in containment, but what’s
being kept out.
A very strange anomaly sits in a humanoid
containment cell in the minimum security wing
of Site 17.
He walks, talks, and looks like a man, but
everything else is convoluted in a question
mark.
This is SCP-343 - Who, like his namesake,
God, is likely to cause arguments whenever
he’s brought up.
Is he the creator of all that exists?
The basis for the Abrahamic Faiths?
Or is he a pretender - A reality warper with
immense power and a predilection towards delusion?
A courtesan of the House of Malidraug?
Matthew?
Methuselah?
Yahweh?
Who knows?
Really, it depends on who you ask, and which
stories you choose to believe.
And few people enjoy a good story more than
SCP-343 himself.
If, one day, you take the time to visit him
in his room, and ask him to reveal a page
in the long book of his personal history,
he might be kind enough to tell you a story.
A story like this - Of an encounter with something
monstrous, that few others could hope to survive
meeting face to face…
Rewind a few thousand years.
Nobody knows how many, exactly.
God - as he chooses to dub himself - walked
across the cracked ground on worn sandals.
It’d been some time since he’d seen an
animal around here, and even longer since
he’d seen a human being.
Not that this bothered him.
He’d never been bothered by his own company
on a long walk like this.
Of course, he could have sped up time or teleported,
but where was the fun in that?
He was a tourist in the world of sensation.
Of experience.
Of flesh, bone, dirt, blood, and sand.
After all, where’s the fun in creating a
whole universe if you can’t drop in now
and then to visit and do as the Romans do?
Not that the Romans would be around for another
few thousand years.
Even Atlas must occasionally shift the weight
of the globe from his shoulders for a jaunt
around the cosmic neighborhood, and whatever
passes for “fresh air” in the vacuum.
God whistled a tune to himself.
It was a craggy, mountainous region he’d
found himself in.
The distant peaks had frosted caps.
A breathtaking place, where many truly had
their breaths taken away.
How humans will so happily risk their lives
to do something extraordinary.
It never ceased to amaze him.
His stomach rumbled.
Oh, how he enjoyed that sensation.
One of the funny little quirks of this human
form that he’d weaved for himself.
It was no reason to be concerned - If memory
served, from his last trip through the area
a few decades before, there was a friendly
village not far from here.
They had always accepted him as a genial stranger,
having no knowledge of his true power.
God had always believed that a person’s
goodness is defined by how they treat those
from whom they had nothing to gain.
So it caused him great concern as he approached
the village, and saw great plumes of smoke
rising into the sky.
He was so shocked by this that he decided
to break his rule about walking as a man,
in case there was still some way he could
help.
With a snap of his fingers, he disappeared
and reappeared in the center of the village’s
town square.
Total devastation.
Huts and houses had been torn asunder.
Broken weapons lay on the ground.
Some places were on fire, others smeared with
streaks of blood, like some terrible battle
had occurred here.
But something was wrong.
No bodies.
Not one, from defender or assailant.
How could a thriving village be so thoroughly
destroyed, and not leave a single corpse?
It was an act so bizarre and depraved that
it even left God puzzling.
That was another downside of his human form:
Here, on earth, he didn’t have access to
true omniscience.
How could a mere human mind, bound by the
constraints of linear time, ever truly comprehend
the totality of existence?
Even attempting to do that here would melt
the brain of his human body in its skull,
and leave it dribbling out of his nose and
ears.
Instead, he chose to walk around the ruins
of the village and investigate firsthand.
Arrows and broken spears and swords littered
the ground.
Some buildings were demolished, but there
were no tracks or stray projectiles that could
suggest the presence of siege weapons.
No, these buildings looked like they were
ripped apart.
Some even still had claw marks…
What terrible beast could have set upon this
town and done this?
Then, he heard a voice, quiet and pleading
beneath some nearby rubble.
A survivor!
He rushed over to the pile and evaporated
it with a thought, Underneath, a feeble old
man, covered in stone dust, was quivering.
God helped him up and guided him into one
of the few remaining huts still standing in
the village.
They both took seats - God held up two hands,
cradling empty space.
Two cups suddenly occupied that space, both
filled with warm, healing tea.
He passed the old man one of the cups while
sipping from his own.
He asked the old man if he’d seen what had
happened.
The old man told him, no, he hadn’t seen
anything in decades.
He’d been rendered blind in his youth.
Little did either of them know, that very
blindness was the only reason he was the sole
survivor of the massacre.
The blind man told God that one of the village’s
scouts had gone up into the mountain with
a small hunting party.
The group was gone for days, until one of
the members - the youngest among them - returned,
weeping, frostbitten, and covered in blood.
He said that his friends had been killed by
a beast in the mountains.
Something that looked almost like a man, but
terribly wrong.
And its face.
Its awful, awful face.
He would never forget it.
He was just lucky to escape with his life
when the others were torn apart.
But when the young man returned, he’d brought
the shadow of death with him.
It was a curse that doomed the entire village
- men, women, and children - to a terrible
fate.
And that fate was upon them a mere hour after
the survivor had returned.
Of course, there were gaps in the blind man’s
understanding, given he was lacking one of
his major senses.
But the sounds he could describe with perfect
clarity.
It was faint and distant at first.
That awful wail, and the galloping.
Hands and feet thundering against the ground,
faster than any horse could move.
Getting closer and closer and closer.
Another villager saw it approaching and screamed,
then it was upon them.
The villagers screamed but it screamed louder.
Always wailing and shrieking and sobbing like
a monster crawled straight up from hell.
People tried to fight it, by the sounds of
it.
The blind man, with teary, blank eyes, recalled
the sounds of arrows nocking and swords clashing
against…
Something.
But even their greatest warriors had screamed
and died.
Those who saw it and tried to flee and hide
were slaughtered all the same.
Soon enough, there were only two sounds left
in the village.
The monster and the blind man, both weeping.
He didn’t understand why it never took him.
It wasn’t fair.
It took everything else.
To leave him here, alive, when everyone and
everything he’d ever known was destroyed,
was a greater punishment than even death.
After killing all of these innocents, the
monster had simply wandered off to the mountains
again, the sound of its quiet sobs getting
smaller and smaller until it was gone altogether.
God comforted the blind man as he wept for
the loss of all his loved ones.
He told the blind man that he would venture
up to the mountains himself and confront the
creature on its own territory, and, at the
very least, find out why it had done this
terrible thing.
But first, he must relocate the blind man
to a safer place.
He placed a hand on the blind man’s shoulder
and he vanished.
He would appear in another friendly village,
miles away.
God sent a silent message into the minds of
every villager: Take good care of this man.
He has undergone horrors you can’t even
imagine.
Your kindness will be rewarded later, for
that, you have my promise.
God sighed and turned his tired eyes to the
distant mountains.
A monster lurked up there - Perhaps one of
his own creations, or maybe a corruption of
one of his creations.
Either way, whatever existed without his knowledge
existed without his consent, and he intended
to know of the beast in the mountains.
Though given what he’d seen already, he
didn’t expect to receive a warm welcome
from this murderous demon.
Miles away, up in the mountains, the creature
licked the blood from its cracked lips.
It looked like it might once have been a human
being or something that aspired to humanity,
or mocked it with its very existence.
It was a huge, gangling beast, skin alabaster,
eyes empty and soulless, dribbling rivulets
of burning tears down a hideous, gaunt face.
It crawled into the frozen mouth of a cave
with great icicle fangs, wheezing and weeping.
All it ever wanted was to be alone.
Why did they have to keep interfering?
Didn’t they know what happened?
All the terrible things they’d made it do…
The creature curled its long, gangly body
into the fetal position, scratching great
ruts into the sides of its bald cranium with
long, sharp fingers.
Terrible things.
Terrible, terrible things…
And then there was a brilliant flash, just
a few feet away.
The monster was surprised, it turned to see
a figure silhouetted in the mouth of the cave.
He wore sandals and thin robes.
His eyes glowed with a kind of power that
the monster didn’t recognize.
This stranger stared at the monster without
an ounce of fear in his heart: He stared right
into its eyes, unwavering.
No!
No, no, no, no!
It could feel it again.
The rage bubbling up, deep down.
A cauldron of seething anger.
It hated the feeling, like being lowered into
a vat of molten metal.
Unspeakable fire and pain coursing through
every vessel.
It began to weep and scream while the stranger
in the cave mouth just watched, not moving
a muscle.
“Do you know who I am?”
the stranger asked with a deep voice that
betrayed almost infinite power, knowledge,
and wisdom.
But it wouldn’t change the outcome here.
The monster bounded at him at speeds that
wouldn’t be seen again until jet planes
and bullet trains are invented millennia into
the future.
Its jaws were hanging impossibly wide, fangs
borne, its arms extended and deadly claws
ready to strike.
But before those terrible hands could close
around the stranger, he vanished.
The monster stumbled and rolled across the
snow, confused.
What trickery was being used here?
“I’ll take that as a no,” said the voice
from behind him.
“You ought to show your father some respect.
More respect than you gave to those poor people
down in the village, at least.”
Seething, the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness of
the cave, staring at him.
But the beast didn’t have the capacity for
awe or holy terror.
Only violence.
Boundless, limitless, unstoppable violence.
It darted towards the stranger again, trying
to strike at him.
Somehow, it was like fighting an empty robe.
Not a single one of its deadly strikes seemed
to hit the stranger.
The stranger leaped backwards, putting some
space between himself and the monster but
still not breaking a sweat.
He breathed in deeply, then exhaled.
The breath came out like a mighty typhoon,
shocking even the monster with its sudden
force.
It was blown backwards, a leaf in the wind,
until its long claws dug into the ground and
anchored it in place.
The stranger gave a wry smile at this, impressed.
“My, my, you’re certainly a tenacious
one, aren’t you?” he said.
“Perhaps we can talk for a little while
instead of fighting.
I want to know why you killed all those people.”
No answer.
The beast roared, its mighty limbs pounding
into the ground as it closed the gap between
itself and the stranger in fractions of a
second.
It would kill him.
Rend him.
Destroy him just like all the others.
He’d left it no choice!
Suddenly, the ground below it seemed to give
away.
The creature was confused.
It looked down to see that the ancient stone
below had somehow taken on the properties
of a liquid, and it was sinking.
The beast panicked and began to thrash.
It was a strong swimmer, but it didn’t expect
to need to swim here.
The shock was too much, and soon, the ground
submerged it entirely, muffling its terrible
roars and shrieks.
And just like that, the ground was solid again,
trapping the beast inside.
The stranger stepped forward and looked at
the ground.
“A much-needed time out,” he said.
“You do yourself no good struggling like
this.”
Despite its terrible capacity for evil, God
couldn’t help but admire the beast, at least
on the level of construction.
It was so pared down, so unburdened.
A killer to the core, but seemingly unkillable.
Had he made this creature?
Billions of species and the species those,
in turn, had created through billions of years
of breeding and evolution, and somewhere along
the line, this thing happened.
It was easy even for the universe’s creator
to lose track of some of the tinier variables.
And in the grand scheme of things, even this
monster was still a tiny variable.
But right here, right now, it was still one
hell of a problem.
The ground rumbled below God.
Cracks formed.
The mountain peak shook.
God raised an eyebrow, genuinely impressed,
as the monster ripped free of its stone prison
and re-entered the fray.
It roared and screamed still, its blank eyes
fixed on him.
Its skeletal body throbbed and heaved with
power.
Unlike any other creature in nature, it was
almost like, the longer their conflict went
on, the more energized the beast became.
God sighed.
All those poor villagers.
They never stood a chance against this monster.
It lunged for him, even faster and stronger
than before.
He teleported out of the way in the nick of
time and the beast’s claws cleaved through
a nearby cave wall, effortless.
God materialized nearby, but he didn’t have
time to speak.
The beast lunged again, and again, and again.
Every time he reappeared, the beast went for
him with impossible speed.
Deciding to widen the playing field, God teleported
to the top of the mountain.
The creature, somehow sensing his presence,
vaulted upwards and tunneled through the roof
of the cave, bursting out of the ground in
front of God, who was floating just slightly
off the ground.
“It would be wise of you to stop,” God
carefully intoned.
“All this time, you know, I’ve been going
easy on you.
You don’t want to find out what the wrath
of God looks like.”
Storm clouds were gathering above.
Mighty thunder roared across the sky.
The beast was undeterred.
It roared and galloped towards God.
And God, in turn, called down a response.
A volley of lightning the likes of which the
world has never seen before or since struck
down on the charging monster.
The sudden white flash could sting the eyes
from miles away.
The monster shrieked from the blast, feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and atomize in
the sheer heat of the electricity around it.
It could smell itself cooking.
The lightning blasts only lasted for a few
seconds, but for the beast, it felt like an
eternity.
When the onslaught stopped, the air was still
heavy with electrical potential.
God stared down at the black scorch mark on
the side of the mountain where the creature
had been standing.
All the snow within the mile had been evaporated
by the blast.
It was a raw display of the power of nature
that would make even Zeus tremble in his sandals.
And yet…
There was still movement.
Something started to get up from the burnt
patch where nothing should be left alive.
A blackened skeleton, rising shakily from
the ash but still very much alive.
As it started to rise, new flesh began growing
over the bones, little by little.
Even God was astonished by the sight of it.
He’d never seen a creature cling so ardently
to life in spite of having truly unsurmountable
power amassed against it.
It was up against God, and still, it fought.
The monster tottered on its freakishly long
limbs, still disoriented, unusually staggered
for a creature driven by such single-minded,
violent purpose.
When enough of its face grew back to do so,
it began to weep and sob again, tears streaking
down its terrible face.
Looking at this creature, after all this,
God couldn’t help but feel a new emotion:
Pity.
He lowered himself to the ground and approached
the creature.
Like none had ever done before, he gathered
it up into his arms and held it, feeling its
heaving, wretched sobs against him.
This beast was in so much pain.
He could feel it, radiating from within.
“Speak, my son,” God said in a soft, fatherly
voice.
And for the first and only time, the monster
spoke, “Can’t look.
Can’t see.
Make me hurt people.
Don’t want hurt people.
Can’t look, can’t look.
Please.”
That was all it managed to choke out before
devolving back into unintelligible babble.
But it was enough.
Enough for God to understand its pain.
He did not know if it would be right to change
the monster’s nature - is it ever right
to truly change anyone’s nature?
- but it was within his almost limitless power
to grant it one reprieve from its pain.
He settled the beast in the snow below him.
It was quiet and still.
And God said unto the beast, “Rest now,
child.
Rest for thousands of years, if you must.
I hope only that when you eventually awaken,
you feel differently…”
And so another story from the catalog of SCP-343.
Of course, it leaves us with certain questions,
chief among them being: Is it true?
Did 343 and 096 have this chance encounter
long ago, or is this just another tall tale
from an anomaly who fancies himself a deity?
We have our truth, and you have yours.
If you’ve ever read the Book of Genesis,
which is the part of the Old Testament that
details God creating the world and humanity
during a particularly busy week, then you
might just already be familiar with SCP-001.
Or at least, one of the anomalies that’s
been proposed for the title of SCP-001.
Because of course SCP-001 doesn’t refer
to a single creature, object or entity, but
rather a collection of various anomalies contained
by the SCP Foundation.
Anomalies sharing the name SCP-001 include
the infamous Scarlet King, a powerful eldritch
being, intent on ending all of creation that
is thought by Foundation researchers to be
one of the most dangerous beings in this,
and any other universe.
But the Scarlet King isn’t the only incredibly
powerful being categorized as SCP-001.
In fact, there are plenty of other anomalies
with similar levels of destructive power.
And one such being is a creature code named
The Gate Guardian.
Standing at well over a thousand feet tall,
The Gate Guardian is impossible to be fully
contained by any means that the Foundation
possesses.
The anomaly itself, despite its colossal size,
is humanoid in its shape, sporting wings that
protrude from its back.
While it usually has four of these, SCP-001
has historically been seen to have any number
of wings between two and 108, sprouting from
various places over its body, including shoulders,
ankles, wrists, and even its temples.
This gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon, referred to as SCP-001-2.
This weapon resembles an enormous knife or
sword, capable of emitting plumes of flame.
According to tests conducted by the Foundation,
the temperature of the flames produced by
SCP-001-2 rival that of our very own sun.
For reference, the sun has a core temperature
of over twenty seven million degrees Fahrenheit,
and 5,778 Kelvin at its surface, or almost
ten thousand degrees Fahrenheit.
You would expect a flaming sword that burns
hotter than the sun to cause a considerable
amount of damage, even if it wasn’t in use,
but the flames emitted by the weapon leave
no lasting damage on the surrounding environment.
It is capable though, of annihilating anything
that strays too close to SCP-001, burning
them so intensely that their atoms literally
separate, breaking potential attackers apart
on a molecular level.
Much as its codename suggests, The Gate Guardian
stands solemnly at the threshold of some form
of dimensional gateway which is equally as
tall as SCP-001 itself.
Behind the Guardian, is a lush grove, abundant
with fruit trees of an astronomical size,
as well as other beings that share a similar
appearance to SCP-001.
This grove is thought to be the Garden of
Eden, the paradise that God created, and that
was inhabited by Adam and Eve, the first two
humans in existence, according to the Book
of Genesis.
As the tale goes, the pair were created by
God himself, and permitted to live in the
Garden of Eden as long as they followed a
single rule.
Adam and Eve were instructed not to eat any
of the fruits that grew from certain trees
that God had specified.
Within view just behind the Gate Guardian
are two immense trees, one bearing apples
and the other bearing different fruit of unknown
type.
The one that looks like an apple tree is believed,
even by some in the Foundation, to be the
biblical Tree of Knowledge that Eve was convinced
to pick a fateful apple from after an encounter
with a snake.
The other, the one with unidentifiable fruit,
is thought to be the Tree of Life.
However, this is all speculation, since it
is currently impossible to venture through
this gateway and verify if the realm beyond
is truly the Bible’s own Garden of Eden.
This is largely because anything that breaches
a kilometer wide radius of SCP-001 is instantly
vaporized.
The Gate Guardian attacks with an imperceptible
speed, using its flaming sword to smite any
person that gets too close.
The Guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye.
It appears to always remain in its solemn,
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and head
bowed, only shifting for a fraction of a nanosecond
to attack.
Ranged attacks against the Guardian are just
as ineffective, with all projectiles fired
at SCP-001 reduced to atoms before they can
do any harm.
Even if said projectile happens to be a nuclear
weapon, The Gate Guardian will be able to
sub-atomically vaporize both the projectile
itself as well as the person who sent it,
regardless of how far away they are.
All while not appearing to lift a finger.
During an experiment involving SCP-001on December
26th, 2004, an SCP Foundation nuclear submarine
called ‘Nautilus’ launched a series of
multi-warhead intercontinental ballistic missiles
at The Gate Guardian.
The retaliation from the Guardian resulted
not only in the deaths of approximately 35,000
innocent civilians, but the blast is also
believed, by some, to have inadvertently caused
the 2004 Boxing Day tsunami.
The severity of this incident came dangerously
close to revealing the Foundation’s existence
to the world, resulting in them rapidly deploying
any means necessary to erase any trace of
the thirty five thousand victims’ families,
friends and other related individuals.
In order to avoid questioning, the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost worldwide
scale, and the O5 council banned any further
tests on SCP-001 that involved nuclear weapons.
In what was hoped by the Foundation to be
a test with lower stakes, they sent an expendable
D-Class personnel towards SCP-001.
The D-Class approached the area where the
Gate Guardian is located, and as soon as they
saw it, they could hear a very clear command
in their mind - “Leave”
The D-Class personnel reacted exactly the
same way you or I would.
They promptly turned and started to walk away.
They didn’t need a thousand foot tall entity
with a flaming sword to tell them twice.
The researchers running the experiment were
not as swayed by the request, and ordered
the D-Class to continue moving towards SCP-001.
When the D-Class continued to ignore their
commands, they were terminated, as is standard
policy when dealing with an insubordinate
member D-Class.
SCP-001 appeared not to like this for some
reason though, and the researcher site as
well as the researchers themselves were immediately
obliterated by an unknown force, though it’s
a pretty safe guess that a certain flaming
weapon was responsible.
This candidate for SCP-001 may be one of,
if not the most powerful being that the SCP
Foundation has ever encountered, and according
to its entry in the SCP-001 file, the Guardian
is even responsible for the creation of the
Foundation itself.
If the file is to be believed, the Administrator
of the SCP Foundation one day heard a word
echoing through his head.
“Prepare.”
This one word instruction led him to starting
the SCP Foundation, containing countless dangerous
anomalies and entities in preparation for
an uncertain future.
In all that time, since the very beginning
of the Foundation, The Gate Guardian has remained
standing at its post.
While it is not aggressive nor openly hostile
towards humanity, The Gate Guardian doesn’t
seem to care much for us either, at least
as individuals.
It rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked, and venturing too close to
the Guardian however, is not an automatic
death sentence.
The Guardian first communicates with any living
being approaching it via a telepathic message,
instructing them to either “Leave” or
“Forget”.
If whomever has stepped too close to SCP-001
complies with the instructions, they’ll
be able to freely leave the area, while simultaneously
forgetting every detail of The Gate Guardian’s
existence.
Ignore these warnings though, and SCP-001
has no qualms about completely eliminating
you from reality.
Given its enormous destructive potential,
it is no wonder that the Foundation has tried
to use The Gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous SCPs, each with varying results.
The Foundation at one time even attempted
to use The Gate Guardian to destroy the infamously
indestructible SCP-682, better known by the
rather appropriate name of The Hard-to-Destroy
Reptile.
Due to the malicious contempt SCP-682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of life,
it is perhaps one of the most dangerous anomalies
the SCP Foundation has in containment.
SCP-682 is also one of the few creatures the
Foundation actively wants to terminate, a
task made that much harder given that 682
can regenerate its entire form from as little
as a single cell.
The Gate Guardian had already shown time and
time again that it was capable of massive
destruction, and researchers working for the
Foundation hoped to harness that power to
rid the world of SCP-682 for good.
682 was placed on an unmanned vehicle and
carried to within one kilometer of the Gate
Guardian.
The guardian attacked the vehicle, seriously
wounding but not killing 682.
It seems even the mighty SCP-001 couldn’t
kill the Hard-to-Destroy Reptile.
While the researchers were disappointed with
this result, it is worth noting that 682 made
a very interesting comment to the Guardian.
682 mentioned that the Gate Guardian is “not
Uriel” but a “pretender”.
Uriel is the archangel that some religious
texts describe as the guardian standing at
the Gate of Eden with a fiery sword, so does
this mean that 682 knows that the Gate Guardian
is not actually an angel?
Or that the location it is guarding isn’t
the Garden of Eden at all?
Any truth or meaning behind these comments
has, as of yet, been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation.
A later experiment involved both SCP-001 and
SCP-073, the anomaly otherwise known as Cain.
Cain is a male humanoid of possible Arabic
descent whose arms, legs, spine, and shoulders
are replaced in an almost cyborg-like fashion
with beryllium bronze.
Much like The Gate Guardian, SCP-073 may also
be the same as the one mentioned in the Bible’s
Book of Genesis who, according to the biblical
story, murdered his own brother Abel out of
spite.
As punishment for his actions, Cain was cursed
to eternally suffer for his wrongdoing.
In the case of SCP-073, any damage inflicted
on him is deflected back to the attacker,
but Cain is made to feel the pain of the attack.
Any plants or plant-based matter withers and
rots in his presence, and he is cursed with
a perfect memory, keeping him forever haunted
by his murder of Abel.
When Cain was brought before The Gate Guardian,
an unknown incident occurred.
The Foundation’s records are heavily expunged,
but we do know that somehow, Cain’s usual
ability to deflect incoming damage back at
his attacker had no effect on SCP-001.
The encounter left SCP-073 unconscious, and
even permanently blinded nearby research personnel.
It was as a direct result of this incident
that the O5 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be conducted
on SCP-001, with the Administrator even filing
an executive order that no SCPs be exposed
to the Guardian, and that SCP-001 was to never
again be used for the attempted termination
of other SCPs.
Of course, perhaps it wasn’t just the mistakes
of the past that made the Council decide that
SCP-001 was best left alone.
At some point, an erratic transmission was
received from Site 0 by Foundation personnel,
detailing an XK-class end of the world scenario.
In the transmission, the sender, believed
to be another member of the SCP Foundation,
described an event during which The Gate Guardian
finally left its post, stepping away from
the entrance to the Garden of Eden.
“SCP-001 has left its location,” the sender
wrote.
“The Gate is Open.
They are riding forth.
Oh God, it's so beautiful…”
The transmission then goes on to repeat various
phrases including “The Lord shall reign
forever” and “Hear, O Israel, The Lord,
our God, The Lord is one”.
What can be inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the end
of the world.
Some believe that, once God deems it time,
his angelic armies will lay waste to the Earth
in order to remake it as a paradise.
When this occurs, SCP-001, The Gate Guardian,
will open the gate he stands in front of,
allowing the other beings like it to emerge
into our world, ready to cleanse it.
Perhaps most interesting is the source of
the message.
The transmission was received from within
the SCP Foundation, from Site 0, however when
questioned by personnel, O5-14 told them that
no such message had been sent, or even existed.
While some initially disregarded the transmission
telling of the end of the world as a hoax,
it was then that a timestamp was discovered.
This warning had not been sent from Site 0,
at least not yet, and was dated several years
in the future.
Despite this ominous warning of things to
come, The Gate Guardian remains inactive,
standing at the threshold to Eden, waiting.
The smell of fire and oil fills the air.
The sound of gears grinding can be heard between
the explosions and shrieks of terror.
A man runs out of his house, only to have
his leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door.
SCP-001 leaves a trail of metal fragments
and mechanical parts on the ground in the
wake of its destruction.
Iron chains swing from its form, cast iron
gears whirl within it, a glowing light throbs
form the center of its body.
SCP-001 is consuming everything in its path.
After incorporating the truck chassis into
its being, SCP-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion
to the next house.
It rips the gutters from the side of the building.
Residents who live in the area flee their
neighborhood.
All the while hoping that the mechanical monstrosity
skips over their house so they have something
to return to if they make it out alive.
A section of SCP-001’s undercarriage drops
away from the main body.
It rolls down the street consuming more and
more material.
The new entity resembles a human spine and
rib cage.
It topples over unable to support itself.
The rib like formations extend out to grab
anything and everything within reach.
The newly incorporated material forms what
can only be described as a head.
Light from within the eye sockets fixate on
nearby civilians.
The metallic creature picks up the people
and places them inside its exposed, steel,
rib cage.
Then it turns and spots a woman helplessly
trying to crawl away.
The creature reaches out with a spiked tentacle
and wraps it around the woman’s body.
She is placed inside of the chest cavity.
Moments later a severed hand falls out of
the entity and onto the ground.
The mechanical monster continues to gather
bodies and materials, incorporating them into
its frame.
A growth begins to slowly expand on its back.
It becomes so massive that the creature falls
over and uses its limbs to scurry into a nearby
house.
There is a sickening crunching sound as the
growth bursts.
From within emerge three humanoid creatures
resembling the civilians that the entity had
consumed earlier.
A female with chains extending from her scalp
like dreadlocks stumbles away.
The second humanoid is a man with cogs for
limbs.
He examines the clock-like components that
have been incorporated into his body, then
stares blankly into the distance.
The third humanoid lies motionless on the
ground.
He did not make it.
The two functioning humanoids look at their
creator intently.
For a moment nothing moves, then as if they
have been given orders telepathically, the
half human half machine humanoids turn and
run away from the mayhem.
A few weeks before the massacre caused by
what would be designated as SCP-001, the Foundation
had been in contact with the Allied Occult
Initiative.
There were rumors of an anomalous object in
Mexico being worshipped by a group of people
who identified themselves as The Church of
the Broken God.
Intel about the Church claimed their deity
was a small mechanical box filled with cogs
and pistons.
The box supposedly had supernatural abilities,
it was said to be able to communicate with
congregants of The Church of the Broken God
telepathically.
The devout worshiped the box, following any
order it gave, and in return they were filled
with an emotion that could only be described
as divine.
As World War II rages on in Europe, the Foundation
sends agents to recover anomalies in Mexico
that might help with the war effort.
While there, the Foundation force is tasked
with learning more about The Church of the
Broken God.
They are also ordered to investigate a town
near La Paz where there are troubling accounts
of a mechanical anomalous creatures causing
mayhem.
The agents make their way through Mexico gathering
various objects to bring back to Foundation
sites in the United States.
The unit loads all of the anomalies they’ve
recovered onto a train with the plan to check
out the stories of the mechanical anomaly
they’ve heard about as they make their way
to the U.S. border.
The train heads north along rusted rails.
Just outside of La Paz they come across a
broken down train filled with what looks to
be refugees.
When the Foundation unit goes to investigate
they find all of the refugees repeating the
same words over and over again but they don’t
understand.
The Foundation agents look at one another
confused, until one of them translates the
words into English.
The words the refugees are saying over and
over again are “la máquina, la máquina…
the machine, the machine,”
The commanding officer orders a squad of Foundation
agents to proceed up the tracks, to see if
they can figure out what has the refugees
so scared.
They make their way towards La Paz, disappearing
over the horizon.
As the sun sets the remaining Foundation agents
hear gunshots in the distance.
They stay awake all night remaining vigilant,
waiting for the exploratory squad, but morning
comes without anyone returning.
Three days later, the Foundation force still
has not seen anything since the exploratory
squad left.
Then as the sun sits lazily in the morning
sky, a lone figure is spotted walking down
the tracks towards the trains.
One of the agents on watch blows his whistle
and points to the figure.
A squad of agents rushes towards the shadow
of a man.
Their guns are raised, ready for anything.
The figure drops to the ground and begins
to crawl along the tracks.
The agents reach the fallen man, only to find
that he is one of their squadmates who had
been sent up the tracks to investigate La
Paz several days before.
The agent’s name is DeMarco.
He is covered in blood.
His clothes are in tatters and he has lost
a boot.
DeMarco lies on his back with Foundation agents
standing around him, his eyes are wide and
wild.
He keeps babbling on about a “world eater,”
how the rest of his squad had been mulched,
and he is the only one who made it out alive.
The Foundation agents carry DeMarco back to
the makeshift base they created by the trains.
They need to figure out a way to get the convoy
moving again, but whatever is up ahead has
taken out an entire Foundation squad.
It had to be something anomalous, but what
could it possibly be?
The unit of Foundation agents prepare to move
towards La Paz.
They start loading their rifles and check
the amount of ammunition and explosives available
in case the containment process gets out of
hand.
Just as they are about to leave the base,
a convoy appears on the horizon.
It is an Allied Occult Initiative force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is devastating
La Paz.
This organization’s mission is not to secure,
contain, or protect, but to destroy.
The Foundation may be in over their heads
on this one, and the joint force with the
Allied Occult Initiative may be the only way
to stop what is now known as SCP-001.
The AOI and Foundation force gears up for
battle.
They set out for La Paz, and what they find
causes them to quake with fear.
SCP-001 has consumed so much material it is
the size of a mountain.
It moves like a tidal wave of mechanical destruction,
washing over the buildings and landscape under
it.
Whatever SCP-001 passes over is consumed and
added to its massive body.
SCP-001 started as a small mechanical box
with cogs, but now has morphed into a gigantic
metal death machine.
The Church of the Broken God has finally met
their maker, as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its members.
Their god is an all consuming monster.
The AOI and Foundation forces do everything
they can to stop SCP-001 from continuing its
reign of destruction.
They fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical anomaly.
They bring in air support to try and damage
it from the skies, but nothing works.
The AOI uses an artifact in their possession
to lure SCP-001 to the coast of the Pacific
Ocean where a trap has been set for the so-called
god.
The monstrous mechanical creature moves slowly
towards the water.
It consumes abandoned cars, buildings, and
boats as it approaches the coastline.
It even shovels large amounts of the earth
into its form, causing flames to spurt out
from its inner workings.
Smoke bellows from openings between different
mechanical components, like a volcano before
it is about to erupt.
Suddenly, seemingly from nowhere, a massive
cloud with a reddish tint appears in the sky.
Air raid sirens can be heard in the distance.
The enormous cloud begins to pulsate.
Streaks of lightning shoot through the red
mist in the sky.
It now sits directly over SCP-001.
From within the cloud part of a ship can be
seen.
It appears to be slightly damaged, electricity
flows over its hull.
The vessel in the giant red cloud is classified
as SCP-2399.
The underside of the vessel begins to glow
aqua blue.
A blinding beam of light is ejected from SCP-2399,
which penetrates straight down and through
SCP-001.
For a moment everything is still.
There is complete silence.
Then as if SCP-001 is trying to reach up and
grab the vessel above it, a mechanical bulge
reaches out.
Before SCP-001 can grab the vessel above,
there is another bright flash of light.
SCP-2399 blinks out of existence.
The sound of grinding gears can be heard coming
from within SCP-001.
It begins to shed its outer layers of metal.
Then the entire structure that was SCP-001
collapses into the water and onto the beach.
Giant cogs fall from the sky.
Parts of vehicles embed themselves in the
sand.
As the Foundation and AOI agents approach
the piles of scrap metal and mechanical components
they see that some of them are still moving.
It is as if an invisible powersource is still
pulsating through some of the machinery.
The agents of the Foundation celebrate the
destruction of the giant mechanical beast,
but little do they know this was only a piece
of the entity worshipped as the Broken God.
The Foundation agents collect as many of the
still moving parts as they can.
They find spinning gears, twitching pulleys,
and firing pistons.
As the parts are separated from one another
and carried away from the main wreckage of
SCP-001, they slowly stop moving and become
inactive.
Some of the artifacts recovered were identified
as being connected to the Church of the Broken
God.
These artifacts are found closer to the middle
of what was once a mountain sized SCP-001.
Hundreds of anomalous artifacts are collected
and transported to SCP Foundation sites.
Collecting the broken parts of SCP-001 is
relatively safe.
However, some agents get too close to the
larger moving parts, getting caught in them
and losing a body part or two.
But most agents proceed with caution and survive
the collection ordeal with their arms and
legs still attached to their bodies.
Dive teams are sent into the water to recover
parts that have sunk to the bottom of the
sea.
One of the divers is a local from the area.
He is hired to bring up the heart of the machine,
since he is an experienced diver used to free
diving to great depths to collect oysters
from the bottom of the bay.
The diver enters the water and swims down
into the murky depths.
He secures straps around the heart of SCP-001
and pulls hard on the rope, as an indication
to the surface that it is ready to be hauled
up.
The salvage team on the surface begins to
pull.
There is a second slight tug on the rope,
then it goes slack.
The team continues to pull.
When they get the heart to the surface they
are horrified at what else comes up with it.
Tangled in the ropes is the lifeless body
of the diver.
His head is smashed between two moving pieces
of the heart.
It looks as if he shoved his head between
the slabs of metal himself.
The salvage team untangles the body, rolls
it off the deck, and back into the ocean.
The mechanical box which was the heart of
SCP-001 is offloaded onto the shore, but as
the Foundation prepares to move it to a containment
facility, the weather starts to deteriorate.
Hurricane force winds sweep across the water
and batter the coast.
The heart is kept in a secured storage warehouse
until it can be moved.
The people living in the village nearby complain
of hearing voices and rashes so itchy that
they practically tear their skin off.
Once the storm passes, the Foundation agents
load the heart onto a ship.
It is to be transported to a Foundation site
just across the border.
The ocean seems calm and serene.
The Foundation ship undocks and begins its
journey up the coast.
Not too long after beginning its journey the
ship slowly drifts off course.
It is as if the crew has stopped manning their
posts, and the ship is being controlled by
a mind of its own.
The Foundation ship crashes and sinks somewhere
in the Pacific Ocean, never to be found, and
more importantly, the heart of SCP-001 doesn’t
make it to the Foundation site.
Years later a man is walking along the beach.
He hears something.
It sounds like someone pounding on a large
drum to the rhythm of a heartbeat.
The man walks towards the sound.
Something is drawing him forward, closer and
closer to the heartbeat.
He walks and walks until the beating stops.
He bends down and moves the sand aside.
He spots the corner of a mechanical box sticking
out of the white sand.
The man digs deeper and pulls out the small
box.
Inside he can see gears whirling and pistons
firing.
He holds the box close to his own heart.
It seems to speak to him.
The man brings the box back to town.
He starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new religion.
They cast aside their old beliefs and focus
on the powerful entity contained within the
box.
God is not dead… at least not yet, but the
prophecies of The Church of the Broken God
say that when the heart is found, the God
will reassemble itself once again.
Then the Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities, until only he remains.
Corpses littered the facility, around twenty
in total.
Their massacre had unfolded in a matter of
seconds despite their advanced armor and heavy
weaponry.
Their killer, wielding an ancient sword he’d
somehow pulled from thin air, looked upon
them with disdain.
Weak, unworthy opponents.
He breathed heavily - His torso was covered
with bullet wounds and many had punctured
his lungs.
It was enough to kill a normal man ten times
over, but not him.
He was the ultimate warrior.
The perfect killing machine.
He would need to seek out an enemy more fitting
for his legendary combat skills.
He fled from the chamber into a connecting
hallway - where a giant, metal door slammed
shut behind him.
At the other end of the hall another door
did the same.
He laughed at the thought of someone thinking
he could be trapped so easily and charged
towards it.
But then, large valves began to open all around
him.
Torrents of freezing seawater began pouring
in, filling up the chamber and submerging
him before he could reach the door.
The warrior fought for breath, and he held
it far longer than any mortal man could - especially
considering the state of his lungs, but water
always wins.
He soon gave his last gasp, and floated, lifeless,
in the hallway.
And soon after his body turned to dust and
disappeared in the briny water.
But he would be back.
He’d always be back.
His brother was a different story.
Tall and handsome, with a strange Sumerian
rune tattooed on his forehead, he was practically
a pacifist and spent most of his days reading,
conversing with the staff, and wandering the
facility of his own accord.
Upon hearing of the latest incident at the
facility, he gave a sigh.
He knew, on some level, that all of this was
his fault.
It’d been centuries, millennia even.
But was it too late to make things right?
Six days later, the two are standing face
to face.
This meeting had been a long time coming,
but it was always destined to end in blood
and pain.
The man with the runic tattoo was unarmed
- the only thing he carried was his regrets.
The warrior, eyes full of burning fury, drew
his sword.
And not long after, a head hit the floor.
Who are these two strange men?
And what is the significance of this fatal
meeting?
In our own universe, these two may never meet
again.
But that doesn’t mean there isn’t a universe
out there where they will.
And it is that universe where today’s tale
springs from.
The story between these two began a long,
long time ago, when they were both set on
a course of destruction.
But to learn how these two finally met once
again, we only need to go back a few days.
While they seem more human than a lot of the
beings under the SCP Foundation’s watchful
eyes, there’s no doubt that these two are
anomalous - they’re known as SCP - 073 and
SCP - 076, but better known as Cain and Able.
From the name alone, most people with a basic
knowledge of the bible could tell that these
two have a connection, but the particulars
were largely a mystery to the Foundation.
They wanted to know how much of the story
was actually true.
SCP Researchers approached SCP - 073 - aka,
Cain - and asked if he’d be interested in
reuniting with his brother one last time.
It took Cain three days to answer: Yes, but
on one condition - that he was the only person
who could abort the mission.
The Foundation mulled over this requirement
for three days before the O5 Council finally
made a decision - Cross-testing approved.
These two brothers, separated by millennia,
would finally meet again - and the SCP Foundation
would get to watch what happened when they
did.
Of course, for safety reasons, the cross-test
would have to take place in 076’s containment
facility - a bedrock chamber two hundred meters
beneath the sea.
That would be the closest thing to “safe”
this fateful meeting could ever be.
Though safe was really a relative term when
it came to SCP - 076.
His escape attempts were as frequent and unpredictable
as they were deadly, and everyone who’d
ever worked with him knew exactly why.
To the untrained eye, it would seem strange
to create such a complex facility for a three-meter-squared
stone cube, known as SCP - 076 - 01.
But the cube isn’t what’s being locked
up here.
The real danger comes from the corpse stored
inside - known as SCP - 076 - 02, but better
known as Able.
He’s a lean, olive-skinned man who appears
to be in his late twenties, but his most distinctive
physical feature is the fact he’s covered
in an elaborate network of arcane and occult
tattoos, largely of scowling, demonic faces
- similar to those found on members of the
Yakuza.
Whenever Able’s corpse reanimates, as it
does at random intervals, everyone in his
vicinity is in terrible danger.
He’s capable of pulling bladed weapons out
of miniature dimensional rifts that appear
around him, though he does this so quickly
that it seems as though the weapons are simply
materializing in his hands.
Despite the increasingly complex efforts to
contain him, Able has been able to breach
containment and go on brutal rampages multiple
times, killing scores of Foundation personnel
in the process.
Able possesses superhuman strength, speed,
and durability.
During prior containment breaches, he was
able to shrug off rounds from .50 caliber
machine guns.
He’s torn through reinforced steel doors.
He’s even swatted bullets from both handguns
and assault rifles out of the air with a length
of steel rebar.
Only killing him can truly end one of these
rampages - and the Foundation has had to go
to terrifying lengths in order to achieve
this during past containment breaches.
He’s been drowned, asphyxiated, crushed,
burned to death with a thermite grenade directly
inserted into his chest cavity, and even disintegrated
by the activation of the facility’s on-site
nuclear warhead.
This may seem like overkill, but if Able ever
made his way into a major population center,
the fatalities would be… well, of biblical
proportions.
Even death can’t keep him down for long
- his body will rapidly decompose, and reappear
intact within SCP - 076 - 01.
There’s no telling when he’ll reawaken,
and his periods of inactivity can range from
hours to years.
Because of this, he must be constantly observed
by guards highly proficient in close combat,
always ready to go toe to toe with perhaps
the most dangerous melee combatant in history.
He’s such a proficient killer that there
was once a project aimed at weaponizing Able,
but this turned out to be a disastrous failure
for the Foundation.
When they ran out of missions to give him,
Able’s thirst for blood caused him to turn
his blade on his allies with no remorse, hacking
them up with the same ruthless abandon he
gave his assigned enemies.
Interestingly, Able does seem to have a twisted
sense of honour.
He has a respect for combatants capable of
providing him with a real challenge - and
has even expressed concern for guards he considers
to be respectable adversaries.
But don’t be fooled.
There is no reasoning with Able - either you
kill him, or he kills you, and trust us, he’s
much better at it than you are.
While he’s often overshadowed by world-ending
anomalies or more talkative mass killers like
SCP - 682, Able is one of the most deadly
creatures known to the Foundation.
Able’s counterpart, 073, is an entirely
different story.
Despite his namesake being the first biblical
murderer, this Cain is a far more enigmatic
figure.
A tall man in his early thirties appearing
to be of Middle Eastern descent, he has two
very notable physical characteristics - The
untranslated Sumerian symbol tattooed onto
his forehead, and the fact that several of
his body parts - namely, his arms, legs, spinal
cord, and shoulder blades - have been replaced
by mysterious prosthetics of unknown origin.
Unlike Able, Cain is polite, non-confrontational,
articulate, and communicative.
He’s even allowed to wander the facility
he’s housed in freely, though with certain
regulations.
Namely that Cain is never permitted to come
into contact with plant life or uncovered
ground.
This is because, in spite of the fact Cain
doesn’t appear to harbor any malicious intent,
direct contact with him causes plants to wither
and die, and the ground to become infertile.
If Cain was ever introduced into a natural
environment again, he could unwittingly cause
an ecological catastrophe with his mere presence.
In that sense, he can be almost as dangerous
to large populations as Able.
However, Cain’s danger to flora is only
one of his several anomalous qualities.
Another is extraordinary mental capabilities,
and a near-perfect memory.
His memory and ability to recall is so good,
that some Foundation personnel have suggested
using Cain’s mind as a kind of backup server
for the Foundation’s collective knowledge.
But perhaps his most well-known anomalous
trait is his ability to act as a kind of immortal
human voodoo doll.
That’s right: Any damage inflicted on Cain
causes no permanent injury to him, and is
reflected back on the perpetrator.
While Cain has remarked on still being able
to feel the pain of these assaults, he’s
functionally immortal.
This damage-reflecting ability has even made
performing certain kinds of tests impossible
- as doctors attempting to draw blood from
Cain have found that their sample was actually
their own blood, and their skin exhibited
the telltale bruising and puncture marks of
blood testing.
But, of most interest to the Foundation right
now was the fact that Cain has shown prior
knowledge of Able.
However, he was cagey when questioned.
He refused to add any additional information,
and commented that it would be best if he
and Able were never brought into contact.
But what does “never” really mean when
you live forever?
Cain finally did agree to the test, and while
nobody knows what caused Cain’s change of
heart, the Foundation knew better than to
push him and potentially get the entire mission
scrapped.
Cain was taken from his facility, and transported
to the access point of Able’s underwater
prison.
The experiment’s design was simple: Cain
would occupy a temporary residence in Able’s
containment facility until he next reanimated,
at which point, the interaction between them
would be closely observed.
Perhaps it would take weeks, months, or even
years before Able once again awoke and left
his cube, but when he did, Cain would be there.
Thankfully, as Cain whispered soothing words
into Able’s tomb, the resurrection took
only minutes.
If you were expecting a heartwarming reunion,
think again.
Cain tried to apologize, but Able immediately
struck him with a decapitating blow which
- due to Cain's damage reflecting properties
- caused him to sever his own head instead.
Cain remained at Able’s side as he regenerated,
and as soon as Able did he immediately tried
killing Cain again.
It went on like this again and again and again.
It was an arduous process, and eventually,
even Able began to tire of it.
The duo fell into a tearful embrace.
Able asked his brother why he killed him,
so long ago.
And Cain apologized, saying it was the actions
of a younger and more foolish man.
In that moment, the two finally reconciled,
and having fulfilled their bargain with their
creator, both finally crumbled into dust.
Peace at last.
As we said, this didn’t happen to the Cain
and Able of our universe, but when universes
are more numerous than grains of sand in an
endless desert, such a thing has indeed happened
somewhere out there - perhaps in a kinder
universe than our own.
We can only hope that our Cain and Able may
someday get to meet and find the same resolution,
but until then, these brothers will remain
one of the most dangerous and fascinating
duos in the Foundation’s catalogue.
“Every time a bell rings, an angel gets
its wings.”
It’s an iconic line from “It’s a Wonderful
Life” and even if you don’t believe in
angels, it’s a pleasant image.
After all, angels are the embodiment of goodness
and light, so an angel getting its wings has
to be a good thing, right?
Well, as anyone who’s ever eaten one too
many Christmas cookies can tell you, it’s
possible to have too much of a good thing.
Even something that sounds like the embodiment
of all things good, in theory, can become
deadly when taken to the extreme.
That is where SCP-469, also known as the Many-Winged
Angel, comes in.
This angel-like creature is anything but innocent
and in fact it has been responsible for multiple
deaths of SCP Foundation personnel during
its captivity.
SCP-469 may be deadly, but it is also undeniably
beautiful in a mysterious, ethereal way.
When first seen, it appears to be nothing
more than a massive pile of pristine white
feathers, like something out of a pillow commercial.
The pile measures 24 feet in diameter and
weighs at least two tons.
However, like many of the entities contained
within the walls of the Foundation’s countless
containment sites, all is not as it seems
with 469.
What looks at first glance to be a pile of
feathers is in fact a dense, curled mass of
giant wings.
The wings vary in size, from the tiny wingspan
of a sparrow to the staggering 3.6-meter wingspan
of the wandering albatross.
The one thing they have in common is their
plumage, with each wing being covered with
the same glossy white feathers.
The Foundation was able to perform a series
of X-rays on the mass of wings, revealing
a skeletal structure beneath the feathers.
Like those of a bird, the wings’ bones are
hollow.
However, they are unnaturally soft and flexible,
allowing for a range of motion that no known
birds possess.
This accounts for the curvature of the wings,
and their ability to coil tightly into each
other.
The X-Ray also provided the first, and only
recorded glimpse at the creature hiding underneath
all of the feathers.
At the center of the layers upon layers of
wings, is a humanoid creature, curled into
a fetal position.
In defiance of the laws of natural anatomy,
every single wing appears to be fused to this
creature’s spine.
How it would be able to move under the weight
of these wings, or if it even could, is as
of yet unknown.
The first Foundation personnel lost to SCP-469
were D-class personnel, D-112 and D-624, who
were sent in to investigate the nature of
the creature and attempt to contact the humanoid
entity identified on the X-rays.
112 and 624 entered the room, equipped with
gloves and protective eye gear, as scientists
watched the situation unfold on a monitor
on a video feed.
No one expected much to come of the encounter,
the working hypothesis was that the layers
of feathers would simply be too thick to get
through without seriously damaging the bones.
It would be a fairly uneventful experiment,
or so they thought.
112 approached SCP-469 first, and attempted
to part a section of its feathers with his
hands as 624 stood back and observed.
The moment his fingertips touched the feathers,
a rustling sound filled the room.
The feathers began to quiver, shaking as if
all waking up at once from a deep slumber.
Suddenly, in the blink of an eye, the hundreds
and hundreds of wings unfurled and pulled
112 into their depths.
He was swept into a swirl of feathers and,
within seconds, he had disappeared from view
completely.
Though 624 and the scientists watching on
their monitor could no longer see him…they
could certainly hear him.
From the moment the wings pulled him into
the sea of feathers, 112 had begun to scream
in agony.
His screams persisted, growing louder and
more desperate even as his voice cracked and
grew weak.
624 stood, frozen in place with fear and shock.
624 was ordered to attempt to retrieve 112
from the feathers, but made no move to do
so.
He simply stared at the feathers, eyes wide,
face pale, as the pained shrieks of his colleague
bounced off the sterile white walls of the
containment room.
A guard called over the intercom, threatening
to terminate 624 if he did not attempt to
remove 112 from SCP-469’s grasp.
This warning seemed to shock 624 back into
action, and he made a run for the center feathers,
arms up to protect his face.
Again, the sound of rustling as the feathers
began to quake.
The wings unfurled once more, and 624 did
not even have a chance to turn back before
he was pulled in to meet the same dismal fate
as the other D Class.
His screams of pain joined 112’s as the
scientists watching over the monitor could
do nothing to help them.
As the two men cried out in pain and horror
from within their winged prison, something
began to happen that the scientists had never
seen before.
The feathers started to shake again, faster
than before, and at first the wings appeared
to be unfolding again.
Upon a second look though, it was clear they
hadn’t moved.
There were simply more of them now.
As the men continued to scream, more feathers
appeared, the wings stretching out and elongating,
and new wings sprouting as if from nowhere.
SCP-469 appeared to be feeding on the sound
of the screams, and using that energy to expand.
It was only after several long minutes when
the screaming finally stopped that the growth
of the wings did too.
At this point, the wings shifted again, expelling
the bodies of 112 and 624 from within its
folds, dropping them limply on the ground.
Though their deaths were unfortunate, the
loss of 112 and 624 did reveal some new information
about SCP-469.
First, that it could grow, and apparently
needed to feed on sounds in order to do so.
Second, that it was deadly to humans, and
most likely to other living things as well.
Autopsies of 112 and 624’s corpses would
later reveal exactly what happened to them,
and how SCP-469 kills its prey.
Though 469’s feathers may look as though
they would be soft to the touch, each feather
is actually made up of sharp barbs that are
capable of piercing clothing and skin.
These barbs release a neurotoxin into the
system that activates every pain receptor
in the body of the victim.
The neurotoxin present in these feathers has
not been identified anywhere else in nature,
but is somewhat similar in structure and function
to the neurotoxins excreted by the cone snail
and in the bite of the blue-ringed octopus.
In addition to the pain-inducing neurotoxin,
the feathers also carry several unidentified
stimulant compounds, which seem to be intended
to keep the victim awake for as long as possible.
Where the neurotoxin on its own would induce
enough pain for the affected party to pass
out almost immediately, the stimulants serve
to keep the victim conscious.
SCP Foundation scientists posit that this
is so that 469 can get as much noise, in this
case in the form of screams, out of its prey
as possible and achieve maximum growth before
the captive creature dies or goes into shock.
Further experiments confirmed this theory,
and showed that SCP 469 will react similarly
when exposed to any living creature capable
of making a sound and experiencing pain, not
just humans.
Nonliving matter though, including dead animals,
elicit no response from 469.
Additional experiments were then undertaken
that involved applying various different sounds
in order to test their effect on SCP 469’s
growth.
Though it feeds on any sounds produced in
its presence, it seems to respond most strongly
to musical sounds, exhibiting a particularly
strong response to classical music.
No sound elicits a stronger reaction from
this creature, however, than the sound of
ringing bells.
It is rumored that when a bell was rung in
the presence of the 469, the humanoid at the
center of the feathers is said to have moved
for the first time on record.
Apparently whatever is at the center appeared
to “wake up” and unfurl its wings, revealing
itself.
But unfortunately, all security footage of
this incident has been wiped, and the data
has been expunged from the record leaving
the creature’s true form a mystery.
You may be remembering that four members of
Foundation personnel on record were lost to
SCP-469, and that only two have been mentioned
so far.
The second pair of casualties resulted when
the Foundation attempted to terminate SCP
469.
Believing that there was no more scientific
benefit to keeping it alive, or at least that
the possible benefits did not outweigh the
risks, it was ordered that SCP-469 be terminated
by any means necessary.
Two skilled personnel, Dr. Jones and Dr. Smith,
were sent into the containment facility in
hazmat gear, armed with several sharp instruments.
They were to attempt to use these to cut through
the forest of feathers and soft bones until
they could reach the humanoid at the center.
It was presumed that once they did and the
creature no longer had the protection of its
poisonous feathers, that it would be relatively
easy to kill.
They could not have been more wrong.
Dr. Jones approached the dense cover of feathers
with a pair of sharpened gardening shears,
while Dr. Smith opted for a machete.
At first, the strategy appeared to be working.
Dr. Jones made several quick cuts, with feathers
fluttering to the floor and sticking to the
Hazmat suit as Dr. Smith slashed into the
feathers with his machete, making similarly
promising progress.
However, the situation quickly took a turn
for the worse when Dr. Jones dropped her shears
and let out a bloodcurdling scream.
The feathers had taken a little longer to
get through the suit to her skin, but somehow
they had managed to find a way just the same.
Smith grabbed Jones and attempted to make
a break for it, but he was too slow, and far
too close to the feathers already.
The wings wrapped around them and swallowed
them both up, leaving the researchers outside
helpless to do anything but listen to their
screams and wait for them to go quiet.
After several minutes they finally did, and
the now larger SCP-469 had officially claimed
another two Foundation personnel.
Obviously, 469 could not be terminated using
any methods that would place the responsible
personnel within its grasp.
That was simply too risky.
So, the Foundation selected a team of D-class
personnel to attempt to burn the feathers
with an array of flamethrowers.
Though the feathers were vulnerable to fire
and began to blacken and disintegrate on contact,
the sound of the flames being expelled was
loud enough to feed SCP 469.
Its growth was so quick in response to the
noise that the fire could not keep up with
the amount of new feathers and wings being
produced.
By the time the flamethrowers ran out of propellant,
469 was the same size as it had been when
they started.
Other termination methods have been discussed,
including the possibility of submerging the
entire creature in a highly corrosive acid,
but so far this has not yet been attempted.
Whatever they end up trying, it is clear that
nothing that produces a significant amount
of noise will be able to kill 469.
So, where is it now?
What’s become of this perverse angel with
the never-ending wings?
Currently, it is kept isolated in an airtight,
soundproof chamber where nothing can trigger
the growth of any more wings.
So, what is it?
An angel?
A demon?
A twisted, mutated bird of some kind?
It is entirely possible we will never know.
But It’s a Wonderful Life had something
right, even if by accident.
Every time a bell rings, something, twisted
and deadly though it may be, gets its wings.
Man, it’s even better on the fifteenth read...
Oh, hello!
I didn’t see you there, dear viewers of
SCP Explained.
I’m on break between supervising SCP-682
termination attempts and inspecting the mops
we use on SCP-173’s leavings, so I decided
to do what all the cool people are doing in
their spare time right now: Rereading Chainsaw
Man, the hit manga by Japanese author and
artist Tatsuki Fujimoto.
For the uninitiated, it’s the story of Denji,
a poor young man from Japan who makes his
living hunting devils - dangerous creatures
that are embodiments of mankind’s greatest
fears.
But when that living leads to him dying at
the hands of a gang of zombie yakuza - believe
me, it makes sense in context - he bonds with
the legendary Chainsaw devil and is reborn
as Chainsaw Man, an unconventional superhero
who chainsaws first and asks questions later.
Naturally, I was eager to see how one of our
own bloodthirsty killers would fare against
Denji’s chainsaws of fury, so I selected
the most violent, battle-hardened, and carnage-hungry
anomaly out there: SCP-076-2, the immortal
warrior known as Able.
The two of them have a surprising amount in
common.
Both are effectively immortal and can revive
after sustaining massive physical injuries.
Both absolutely love to fight with their array
of deadly weapons and anomalous strength.
Both have been part of experimental operations
groups - with Denji being a member of Japan’s
Public Safety Devil Hunter’s Division 4,
and Able being an ex-member of the SCP Foundation’s
disastrous Pandora’s Box Mobile Task Force,
most of which he later massacred out of boredom.
You can probably see why these two really
did feel like the perfect match-up.
So after forcing the trusty Anon-O-Tron 6000
to read every currently available volume of
Chainsaw Man, and compute years of Able’s
gruesome battle data, I’ve set up the perfect
simulation for your viewing pleasure.
And hey, fellow fans of the manga, isn’t
it horrifying that even we beat MAPPA to the
punch of animating this thing?
God, that joke will age poorly if that anime
comes out before this.
Anyway, let’s crank this machine into action
and let her rip!
Japan, 1997.
Everything is roasting in the July Heat.
Men In Black, Harrison Ford’s Air Force
One, and Air Bud are hitting theaters for
the first time.
Everything is right with the world.
That’s why, over in the headquarters of
the Public Safety Devil Hunting Department,
Denji - our Chainsaw-loving hero - is being
praised by his kind boss and mentor figure,
Makima.
A lovable, supportive woman who will never
do anything wrong.
She even loves dogs - how could a person who
loves dogs ever be evil?
That very morning, Denji, in his Chainsaw
Man form, managed to defeat the Accidentally
Making A Mistake On Your Tax Forms And Now
You’re Going To Prison Devil, who had been
terrorizing downtown Tokyo.
It was a challenging battle, but in the end,
he’d managed to turn the tables and defeat
the creature by setting it on fire.
Needless to say, Makima was extremely pleased
with Denji’s work here, but now, she had
considerable graver news to impart.
She’d gotten word from an envoy of another
organization that hunts down dangerous and
anomalous creatures - the SCP Foundation - that
an extremely lethal entity had breached their
containment and was now somewhere in Japan.
The entity in question was not a devil, and
thereby would be working on a different rule
set.
Makima opened a file faxed to her by the Foundation
- yes, remember, this is set in 1997 - and
gave Denji the crucial lowdown.
Several hours ago, the entity known as Able
had resurrected from his huge, black sarcophagus
in the underwater chamber of the classified
facility, Containment Area 25b.
After waking up, Able had slaughtered his
way through the entire base, killing every
SCP Foundation operative in his path and then
swimming out into the Pacific Ocean.
Sometime after that, he infiltrated a Japanese
cargo ship and murdered all the workers on
board, before steering the ship back towards
the land of the rising sun, where he hoped
to claim even more victims.
Makima told Denji that it would fall to him
and his associates to stop this Able, with
a little help from the SCP Foundation’s
intelligence.
But be warned: Able is an incredible combatant
with extreme physical strength and durability,
as well as surprising tactical intelligence.
It wouldn’t be an easy fight, but Makima
promised that if Denji won, she’d hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him.
Denji replied, “Consider him dead already,
Miss Makima.”
Meanwhile, Able was walking through the slums
of Tokyo, marveling at the neon signs for
bars and clubs.
His journey to Japan hadn’t been an accident.
Able had been to Japan once before, in the
year 1605.
He’d faced the legendary Japanese philosopher
and Swordsman Miyamoto Musashi, considered
by many to be one of the greatest warriors
in human history.
Able had dueled Musashi - who famously wielded
two Katanas at once - in the hills of the
Harima Province, where, after a tense battle,
Musashi cut him down.
Able would not resurrect again during Musashi’s
lifetime, but the battle gave him a deep and
abiding respect for the legendary warrior.
Able knew that if the opportunity ever rose
again, he would return to Japan, in hopes
of experiencing such a brilliant battle yet
again.
But the industrial and technological boom
had changed so much.
It was no longer the quiet and pastoral Japan
he’d experienced, but a booming epicenter
of trade and commerce.
He found it all strange and perplexing.
Suddenly, he found himself surrounded by a
group of Japanese street toughs, many of them
wielding switchblades.
They laughed at his strange outfit, which
to them looked like an old, worn bedsheet.
One of the smarter members of the group had
already decided to go home when the others
made up their mind to mug Able - the warrior’s
extensive tattoos made him look like a Middle-Eastern
yakuza don.
The rest, however, were happy to take their
chances with him.
“Empty your pockets, if that goofy toga
even has pockets,” the leader said, holding
up his switchblade.
“Unless you wanna get cut.”
Able just smirked and drew a pair of long,
obsidian daggers.
In the following moment, the alley was filled
with screams, then was silent yet again.
Able walked on, breathing a sigh of disappointment
at how incredibly mediocre this first fight
had been, his blades dripping with fresh blood.
Musashi is rolling in his grave, Able thought
to himself.
Meanwhile, across town, Denji and the rest
of Division 4 were mobilizing.
It was him, the serious, sword-wielding Aki,
and the adorable, pathologically-lying Blood
Fiend, Power.
They’d been told over the phone by a man
named Dr. Bright that Able would be relatively
easy to track down - He’s not known for
his subtlety; all you need to do is follow
the trail of carnage he causes wherever he
goes.
From the way he talks about him, it seems
almost as though Dr. Bright bears a personal
grudge against Able.
How strange.
Power didn’t seem intimidated.
She proudly proclaimed, “I don’t think
this battle will be difficult at all.
In fact, I’ve faced this Able before and
defeated him handily.”
Aki sighed and asked.
“When did this happen?”
“Last Tuesday, of course!”
she replied.
Power had only heard about Able this morning,
but Denji and Aki had learned better than
to dispute her at this point.
Suddenly, a large television screen that had
been previously relaying an ad for a cutting-edge
stereo system cut to an emergency news report.
There’d been a horrific incident in downtown
Tokyo, where a bar had been attacked and most
of its patrons murdered by a deranged, tattooed
man carrying a pair of huge swords.
Aki immediately recognized the place - The
bar was yakuza-owned.
If this Able was on the hunt for worthy opponents,
it makes all the sense in the world that Japan’s
iconic crime syndicates would be his first
target.
Denji, Aki, and Power knew exactly where they
needed to go.
Over at the bar, Able was having a whale of
a time.
Innocent patrons were running and screaming,
while the Yakuza engaged in an all-out war
with the terrifying, inhuman warrior.
Several of them had already been cut down.
Two Yakuza soldiers behind the bar were reloading
illegal Uzis and preparing to return fire.
Both were sweating, terrified by the sudden,
random attack.
When they’d shot him before, he’d managed
to dodge most of the bullets, and expertly
block the rest with his swords.
Who the hell had sent this monster?
Was he with the Triads?
The Russian mob?
Or some devil summoned by the Japanese government
to crack down on them?
Whatever the case, he seemed almost impossible
to kill.
The two men stood back up and opened fire.
Able held his two swords and spun them like
a propeller, blocking all the bullets almost
effortlessly.
He then produced another dagger, seemingly
from thin air, and threw it directly into
the heart of one of the two remaining Yakuza
behind the bar.
He dropped to the ground, dead instantly,
leaving only his friend alive in a bar full
of corpses.
That’s when Able noticed a decorative katana
behind the bar.
He smiled and ordered the surviving Yakuza
soldier to pick up the sword and give him
a real fight.
The hapless mobster realized in that moment
that this guy was truly crazy, whoever he
was.
But what choice did he have now?
With terror in his heart, the last surviving
Yakuza grabbed the katana and unsheathed it.
“Good,” Able said, his voice deep and
menacing.
“Now come fight me.
Let’s see if you last a few seconds longer
than your worthless friends, shall we?”
He did not.
The second the Yakuza ran towards Able, and
the ancient Swordsman swiped at him with one
of his blades, cutting through the katana
and then the opponent holding it.
A puny gangster never stood a chance against
a deadly immortal warrior, and Able was furious.
The last time he was here, he faced a truly
expert killer,
who’d even managed to end Able’s life
in single combat.
And now he was slaying insects in a karaoke
bar.
Pathetic…
Suddenly, his ears pricked up.
He turned to see a red axe flying at his head
at incredible speeds.
With his superhuman reflexes, he managed to
dodge just in time, but the axe still cleaved
off a chunk of his hair as it passed.
Able could see the one who threw it standing
at the entrance to the bar: It was the Blood
Fiend, Power, who’d made the axe out of
her own blood.
Standing next to her were Denji and Aki, Denji
wielding an axe and Aki stoically observing.
“Damn, Miss Makima promised we’d do karaoke
at this bar if I beat you,” Denji said.
“You’re going down for this.”
Able smiled and pulled out another pair of
blades.
“Finally!” he roared.
“Warriors who fight the old-fashioned way.
I feared the years had stolen you all from
me.”
Power stepped forward, producing another blood
axe from nowhere.
She yelled, “Tremble in fear, Able.
‘Tis I, your archnemesis, the mighty Power!”
Able had literally never seen her before in
his thousands of years of life, but he appreciated
that these warriors were at least able to
match his level of drama.
As far as he was concerned, the fight was
on.
But even Able didn’t know the level of fighting
he was getting in for here.
As he charged forward, the trio split, immediately
surrounding him.
Good tactics, Able thought to himself.
Already, this was promising.
Aki, who had remained quiet up to this point,
attacked first.
He drew a tanto knife from his suit jacket
and slashed at Able with impressive speed.
But unlike three of the other combatants in
this situation, Aki was only human, which
gave him a serious disadvantage.
Able decided it would be best to put him out
of commission first.
With a quick and brutal kick to the chest,
Aki was thrown against the wall with the majority
of his ribs broken.
Revved up by his own bloodlust, Able turned
to Denji and Power and grinned like a maniac.
This was already the most fun he’d had in
a long time.
Who are these people?
Doesn’t matter, he thought.
They’ll be dead soon anyway.
While Able was still locked in thought, Power
pulled out a comically large hammer made out
of her own blood, and brought it down towards
Able.
He was surprised by the sudden attack - Did
this girl have the same weapon-producing powers
as him!?
This just keeps getting more interesting!
“‘Tis the end, Able!”
Power screamed as the hammer came down.
“You have once again been defeated by the
mighty Power!”
Again, just to clarify, these two had never
met each other.
But it was already too late.
Able punched upwards, his clenched fist colliding
with the hammer.
He hit it with such terrifying force that
Power’s blood hammer shattered against his
knuckles.
In that same instant, Able noticed Denji running
at him with an axe from behind.
Able produced another obsidian dagger and
threw it into Denji’s forehead, dropping
him to the ground immediately.
Pathetic.
Power tried to produce another weapon, but
she’d used up too much blood already.
Before she had a chance to make anything substantial,
Able sprung forwards with terrifying speed,
trying to land a killing blow.
But even weakened, Power was freakishly fast.
She was able to dodge his blow and kick him
in the ribs, momentarily stunning him.
Of course, she took the time to gloat, putting
her hands on her hips and laughing victoriously.
“Need a second to catch your breath, Able?
It is to be expected.
None can keep up with me!”
She grandiosely announced.
“Perhaps you should just give up and agree
to become my servant.
I might even teach you a thing or two about
fighting—“
Suddenly, Able was standing right in front
of her, squeezing her throat with his iron
grip.
He smiled, flashing teeth, and said, “If
you want to kill, kill.
Don’t talk.”
With a surprisingly minimal amount of strength,
he squeezed and heard a crunch from Power’s
neck.
He dropped her limp body to the ground.
Lucky for Power, Able wasn’t aware that
a Fiend like Power can survive an injury like
this as long as she’s fed some more blood.
Instead, he just sighed in disappointment.
“Is that all you weaklings have to offer?”
He bellowed.
Aki, barely conscious after being kicked against
the wall, remained just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a powerful beast
known as the Fox Devil.
He twists his hands into a strange gesture
and whispers the word, “Kon”, before falling
unconscious.
But that’s still enough.
Suddenly, a giant demonic fox claw burst through
the wall of the bar, spraying dust and rubble
everywhere.
Able was definitely not expecting that.
He dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him, often barely missing him.
For its last strike, it lunged forward and
raked four claw marks across his chest.
Able was shocked by the sudden pain.
It felt fantastic.
He pulled a long, obsidian spear out of one
of his pocket dimensions, and forced it down
through the Fox Devil’s paw and into the
ground, pinning it in place.
After a moment of thrashing, the claw dissipated
into smoke, lending Able another victory - though
even he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been.
Was that it?
Had he gained total victory once more, just
like he so often did these days?
He was about to take pity on himself when
Denji rose up behind him.
“How about a rematch?”
Denji asked.
Able grinned.
He liked this kid.
“Challenge me, child,” Able said.
“Well, since you asked...”
Denji smirked.
Denji reached into his shirt and grabbed the
rip cord emerging from his chest.
It was time to go into overdrive on this thing.
He gave it a mighty yank, and like the rev
of a chainsaw, the madness began.
Denji transformed - Giant blades emerging
from his arms, and his head transforming into
a toothy, saw-blade nightmare.
He gave a mechanical roar that spewed smoke.
This wasn’t just Denji anymore.
This was Chainsaw Man.
Now this, Able thought, feeling his adrenaline
spike, is more like it!
Following Denji’s lead, Able reached into
one of his pocket dimensions and pulled out
one of his favorite weapons - one he’d only
previously used against the mighty Hard to
Destroy Reptile, SCP-682: The Chainsaw Claymore,
a huge, two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting, shredding teeth of a chainsaw ever
circulating around it.
It was time for Chainsaw Vs Chainsaw.
“What the hell are you waiting for?”
Chainsaw Man roared.
“Are we gonna stand around all day, or are
we gonna fight?”
Able couldn’t have said it better himself.
The two charged at one another at lightning
speeds, chainsaw clashing against chainsword.
The sheer force of contact was enough to send
a shockwave blasting through the bar.
It rapidly became a power struggle, each one
of them trying hard to force their chainsaws
out of the stalemate.
Realizing that this time he perhaps couldn’t
win with raw strength, Able backflipped away
to reassess his options.
But Chainsaw Man had no intention of giving
Able time to think about it.
He darted towards Able with the weight and
momentum of a runaway freight train.
If Able hadn’t raised his claymore to parry,
he would have been shredded to pieces by the
devil’s saws in an instant.
Instead, the two of them rocketed out of the
nearby wall in a cascade of debris, causing
everyone on the outside street to run for
their lives.
The two quickly stood from the stumble, catching
their breath.
“Impressive,” Able said.
“You’re much better than the others.”
Instead of replying, Denji briefly retracted
his arm chainsaws and grabbed a nearby parked
car, throwing it directly at Able.
Able reacted quickly, cleaving the car in
half with his claymore and charging for Chainsaw
Man again.
Just before Able could land a lethal strike,
Chainsaw Man deployed his chainsaws again,
blocking the blow.
Able sped around him, trying to strike again
and again, but Chainsaw Man blocked every
strike with stunning efficacy.
Able was astonished - few had ever been able
to go toe to toe with him like this before.
He could feel his heart pounding gloriously
in his chest.
He would give Denji a warrior’s death.
With a furious yell, Able brought down the
Chainsaw Claymore for a devastating vertical
strike, but Chainsaw Man was ready.
He arranged his arm chainsaws in a cross formation,
like a giant pair of scissors, and caught
Able’s chainsword between them.
Chainsaw Man pulled his arms in opposite directions,
slicing Able’s mighty sword in half.
The immortal Swordsman skidded backwards to
avoid the fallout, producing two smaller blades
immediately.
This Chainsaw Man just kept exceeding expectations,
didn’t he?
Able would need to change tactics if he wanted
to win this one...
Chainsaw Man was impressed by the speed and
tenacity of his foe.
For someone who apparently wasn’t even a
devil, Able sure packed a hell of a punch.
Did he ever run out of those damn weapons?
As though attempting to answer Chainsaw Man’s
question for him, Able began running around
his flank, rapidly producing and throwing
blades and axes in a startling volley.
Chainsaw Man was able to use his Chainsaw
arms and face to block most of them, but not
all of them.
Several daggers and small throwing axes splattered
into the tender flesh of Chainsaw Man’s
chest.
Able had successfully wounded him, and he
wasn’t done.
Feeling a little more confident now, Able
decided to take a different tactic: He produced
a large, spiked mace from thin air, and ran
at Chainsaw Man while the devil was still
recovering from his projectile attack.
With one brutal whack, he sent Denji flying
down the street, carving a rut into the concrete
beneath him.
But Able wasn’t done.
While Chainsaw Man was still trying to recover,
Able leaped onto him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace.
The strikes were so brutal they shook the
earth and sent cracks across the surrounding
ground.
Then Able stopped.
He realized, for a moment, that he was letting
his blood lust get the better of him.
This was dishonorable.
Where would be the fun in beating this boy
to death while he lay on the ground, and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents he’s
had in quite some time?
No, that wouldn’t do at all.
He’d give him one more chance.
“On your feet, boy,” Able said.
“You fight well.
Get up and carry on.
I won’t let a beast as rare as you die like
a common dog.
Rise and fight me!”
And Chainsaw Man did as he was told.
Able was shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as Chainsaw Man burst up through
it, all his swords at the ready.
The mace was thrown from Able’s hands as
Chainsaw Man launched up towards him, all
metal teeth and fury.
Luckily for Able, he pulled out a battle axe
just in time to block the flurry of brutal
strikes from the patron saint of chainsaws.
Now this was a fight even Musashi would be
proud of.
“Yes, boy, yes!”
Able yelled.
“This is true combat!”
Chainsaw Man replied with the swing of his
blades, which Able was narrowly able to dodge.
The two finally landed back down on the ground,
and Able was fast enough to bury his battle
axe in Chainsaw Man’s shoulder.
Before the devil could return a blow to Able,
the anomalous Swordsman pulled out a pair
of his favorite swords and locked Chainsaw
Man’s arms in place.
Chainsaw Man was undeniably incredibly powerful,
but it looked like Able’s superior experience
and tactics might save him this time.
“What the hell are you?”
Chainsaw Man roared.
“You’ve been a worthy opponent, boy, those
are few and far between,” Able said.
“I’ll remember you for this...”
But before Able could execute a killing blow,
he felt a blood red throwing axe stick into
his back.
Able winced in pain and turned to see Power
and Aki about thirty feet behind him.
Power was propping Aki up - he’d donated
some of his blood to bring her back to life.
And she was just as delusionally cocky as
ever.
“Tis I once again, my arch-nemesis!”
Power yelled.
“Did you really believe you could beat me
so easily?”
Able was about to say something, but he’d
already made a fatal mistake: Letting his
guard down.
Before another word could pass the cursed
warrior’s lips, one of Chainsaw Man’s
arm chainsaws passed directly through his
heart, tearing it apart within Able’s chest.
It was a sudden and decisive killing blow.
Chainsaw Man pulled his saw back out of Able’s
chest, stained with the deadly anomaly’s
blood.
Able collapsed to the ground, wheezing and
bleeding profusely from the hole in his chest.
But strangely, as Power, Aki, and Chainsaw
Man converged around him, they realized he
was smiling.
“Thank you...”
Able said, and died yet again.
With the battle won, like an extremely metal
Incredible Hulk, Chainsaw Man transformed
back into Denji.
The trio stood around Able’s corpse, deeply
confused as to what had just happened.
If this was the kind of thing the SCP Foundation
normally dealt with, they all silently agreed
that perhaps it would be better not to get
involved with them in future.
Except Power, of course, who said, “You
two should be thanking me for defeating him.
You both owe me drinks for this!”
Hundreds of miles away, in a black sarcophagus
deep underwater, surrounded by professional
SCP Foundation divers, Able’s body once
again returned.
Who knows how long he’d remain sleeping
in there?
But what we do know is that his deathless
sleep was suffused with sweet dreams, knowing
that this world still held worthy opponents.
And for Able, that was everything.
We’d been so cautious, keeping quiet, covering
up, only moving at night, but sometimes, despite
all your best efforts, you just get unlucky.
We made our way through what we thought was
an abandoned street, littered with broken-down
cars, when those...
Things had slithered out and ambushed us.
Kaspar, who was always the most trigger happy
of us, panicked and opened fire with his scavenged
submachine gun on the largest of the creatures.
Big mistake.
It didn’t slow the monster down, and only
seemed to attract more.
It’d be blob city before sunrise now.
But poor Kaspar wouldn’t make it that long.
Fleshy tendrils wrapped around his limbs and
pulled him into the terrible mass of one of
the creatures.
It started reshaping around him, enveloping
him as he screamed, until the tide of flesh
coursing down his throat silenced him.
The whole time, the monster just kept gibbering
madness in a warped voice.
“Become one, yes, let our cells bond and
our minds coagulate in the glorious shimmering
light.
We will all be one in daylight, pretty flower,
yes, yes, yes...”
And then there were four.
Me, Ellen, Darcy, and Jones.
There had been more of us once, but in this
war of attrition, we always seemed to be the
ones who had to lose.
And if we didn’t get away from these monsters
quickly, then there wouldn’t be any of us
left soon enough.
We ran, ducking and weaving around the cars
as the blobs got closer.
There were so many of them, all howling and
ranting, zealots for the only cause their
melted excuses for minds could understand
anymore.
Occasionally, we fired back, hoping to slow
them down a little - But it never worked.
The guns, if anything, were a psychological
support mechanism, and something to scare
off other survivors who were even more desperate
than us.
When it came to the blobs, especially the
big ones, the only things you could do were
run and hope.
And hope’s in short supply these days.
No matter how fast we ran, the blobs kept
catching up, and they didn’t seem to get
tired.
Knowing we couldn’t outrun them, we ran
up to one of the abandoned cars and crouched
behind them, breathing raggedly.
This whole stupid mission, in hopes of eventually
reaching safety, a good night’s sleep behind
solid walls, and some people who actually
know what the Hell is going on.
I drew my sidearm out of my pocket.
Even if I didn’t make it out of here, I
wouldn’t turn into one of those monsters.
Pulling back the hammer, I muttered a quiet
prayer.
If there’s a God out there, he had a hell
of a lot to answer for right now.
I looked to Ellen, Darcy, and Jones, and they
all had the same idea.
It was a pleasure to know them all, after
everything that’d happened.
We heard the blobs getting closer, their lunatic
whispers growing in volume and intensity,
as they always did before they claimed one
of us.
I breathed a sigh, ready to accept my fate,
knowing what I needed to do.
It all seemed to be over.
Until He appeared.
I looked up and spotted a strange man approaching.
He was dressed in an old-fashioned hessian
toga, His hair and beard frosty white.
I couldn’t identify His age or race, but
those factors seemed secondary to the fact
His eyes were glowing brilliant white, as
if exuding pure energy.
He raised a hand, the same glowing aura of
pure white energy emanating off of it.
I’d seen so many things that terrified me
in the past six months.
But this...
This was the first time I’d experienced
something I could call “Awe.”
He walked towards us with a stillness and
confidence and said “You look like you could
use a hand.”
Where were you when day broke?
Whoever’s left, they remember.
I was in a supermarket with my wife and two
kids, just another normal day.
I was worrying about bills, taxes, and whatever
we were going to have for dinner that night.
If the Devil exists, I’d sell my soul to
the nasty red creep to get those worries back.
Lucky for us, we were in the back half of
the store, lit entirely by artificial light.
The people checking out their groceries down
front, right in front of the building’s
huge, glass facade, they were the first to
go down.
All these terrible drowned screams.
First, the exact kind of shrieks you’d expect
from somebody starting to melt.
Then, the gurgling, like a backed-up drain,
as their mouth and throat melted around the
sound, choking it.
Those were the first minutes of Hell on Earth.
I’ve never been the smartest man.
I was a roofer, back when things made sense.
Never went to college, never been much for
reading, but I had intuition, and I credit
that with surviving this long.
My dad was in the service.
Two tours in ‘Nam.
He always told me when I was a kid, the guys
who didn’t make it back, they panicked.
Because that’s what the enemy wants you
to do.
They hope, when everything hits the fan, you’ll
break formation, forget the plan, and all
start scurrying in different directions like
rats, just hoping you’ll be the one who
finds a crack and gets out.
That’s when they get you.
When you panic, you’re giving up the birth
rite of reason and letting the animal take
over.
“And animals, son, are easier to kill.”
When the sun went bad that day, plenty of
people in that store started running.
They didn’t know what they were running
from, or where they were running to.
They just wanted to put some distance between
themselves and the screaming.
Every man for himself.
I’d love to tell you all those people are
dead now, but in actuality, they were in for
a far worse fate.
They ran out of the safety and cover of the
store, putting themselves at the mercy of
the light.
Even as they melted, they kept running.
They were blobs, slithering away, not even
knowing that the thing they were running from
had already gotten them.
It all happened so fast, but I can remember
every single detail.
You can judge me if you like.
I don’t care anymore.
If I could have spoken reason to those terrified
people that day, hand on my heart, I would
have.
But one of man’s greatest design flaws is
that God made fear the master of reason.
Nothing I could’ve said that day would’ve
changed anything.
The only ones I could hope to save were my
family, so that’s exactly what I did.
We grabbed what we could, stayed away from
windows, and made our way to the nearest supply
closet.
We were in there for hours, and we didn’t
come out until things were actually quiet.
Which, coincidentally, happened to be at night.
When we stepped outside of the store, we saw
the carnage that must’ve unfolded over the
past few hours.
Windows smashed.
Cars driven into storefronts and abandoned.
Slithering blobs of former-people on the ground.
In the space of a few hours, the world had
truly and irrevocably changed.
No matter what happened, even if we survived,
we knew there would never be a “normal”
as we’d known it before ever again.
The same message was playing on every TV,
radio, and computer.
A logo I didn’t quite recognize, along with
an overlay that read, “An Important Message
from the SCP Foundation.”
It explained, in an eternally looping, robotic
voice, that they were superseding the control
of all world governments to protect humanity
from this new and terrifying threat.
In short, the sun had turned against us.
In some scenarios, survival is a curse.
In those early days and weeks, you wouldn’t
believe the number of times I started to envy
the dead.
People who’d been wiped off the mortal coil
by diseases and car crashes and random acts
of violence in the days before Day Broke,
they had no idea how good they had it.
Little by little, in this terrible new world,
death became a kind of luxury.
Because melting under the fiery gaze of the
sun?
That wasn’t death.
Not even close.
They seemed harmless at first.
Tragic, pitiful, really.
The voices on the TV even told us that, to
avoid starvation, we could eat small parts
of the melted.
But, over time, the situation evolved.
I don’t know when it started, or why, but
the blobs that had once been people started
coagulating.
They joined up, started turning into bigger
creatures, all with one mind, always screaming
and talking madness in a collage of stolen
voices.
These monsters existed for one purpose, and
one purpose only: Finding the people who were
still normal and dragging them out into the
light to join them.
They roamed the world during the night, hunting,
seeking.
And given night was the only time we could
ever safely move, this created problems for
all of us.
We lost so many to those terrible monsters.
Including my wife and both my kids.
See what I mean about survival sometimes being
a curse?
Especially when you’ve got people to miss.
I wish they were dead, all three of them,
but I still hear them - their voices added
to the chorus of a house-sized flesh monster.
But I lived on, if you can call this living.
I met with others, like Kaspar, Ellen, Darcy,
and Jones.
All of them had lost people.
You hadn’t lived this long if you hadn’t
lost people.
We did all we could to keep surviving against
the odds.
We spent our days in basements and abandoned
stores, and our nights dodging the flesh creatures
and foraging for food.
We eked out each day, taking every breath
as it came.
We didn’t hope for anything.
Until one day, we heard that the people at
the SCP Foundation might know how to reverse
all this.
They needed all the people and help they could
get at one of their bases, around twenty miles
away from us.
It’d only be a couple nights walk to get
there, we figured, so why not help out the
cause?
Safety in numbers, after all - And, truth
be told, we’d missed people.
After days of hiding and nights of traveling,
we were ambushed, but you already know about
that part.
We lost Kaspar to one of those monsters and
got cornered behind an abandoned car.
However, as the blobs got closer and closer,
that mysterious stranger with the glowing
eyes appeared.
He didn’t walk like the rest of us.
He was bold, confident, His back straight
as a dancer’s.
Like He feared nothing.
Like nothing here could hurt Him.
Suddenly, I felt a rumbling behind me.
The car was rattling.
I feared for a second that the blobs were
crawling over it to get us, but when I turned,
I saw the opposite was happening.
The car was rising off of the ground, free-floating.
Myself and the other survivors stared in astonishment
as the stranger simply flicked His wrist.
The floating car was thrown with tremendous
force at the largest of the advancing blobs.
It hit the beast so hard that the top of it
simply splattered off, freezing what was left
in place.
Even the other blobs paused, seemingly astonished.
We all turned to the stranger, still standing
firm.
“Stand behind me if you wish to live,”
He said.
There was something both passionate and commanding
about His voice.
It was impossible to hear Him and not heed
His words.
All of us stood up and ran behind the stranger,
as He lifted both hands.
Debris climbed into the air.
Cars, rocks, broken glass.
The blobs were beginning to coagulate again,
but this time, the stranger wasn’t going
to let them get the upper hand again.
With a slight nod, everything He’d raised
flew at the blobs with the force of a machine
gun.
They were decimated.
The bigger ones, cut apart.
The smaller one fleeing to avoid the onslaught.
After months of running from these monsters,
I don’t think any sight could have been
more satisfying.
When the creatures were gone, the stranger
just gave a quiet sigh.
He turned to us and asked if we were okay.
The answer was, essentially, “About as much
as we can be.”
He told us that we’d be safe as long as
we stuck with Him, and after that display,
we had every reason to believe Him.
We followed the stranger down the long, dark
road.
He always walked in the middle, fearless,
making no attempt to hide.
When we asked Him His name, He told us that
He goes by many names, but for the sake of
simplicity, we could call Him Matthew.
We thanked Matthew for saving us, and He gave
a sad sort of smile, and told us that He only
wished He could have done more.
There was something so strange about Matthew,
even beyond the fact He apparently had superpowers.
I’d never met the man before and I’d be
willing to bet my right hand on that, and
yet, it felt like I’d known Him my entire
life.
He was so different, and yet, so incredibly
familiar.
We told Him we were on our way to a nearby
SCP Foundation facility, where we were told
we’d find safe haven.
We asked him if he knew where to find it.
Matthew told us that, in fact, He’d lived
in that very site for decades, a visitor,
just dropping in.
He’d had a very stressful job before, and
felt like taking a sabbatical while things
ran themselves for once.
“Evidently, my help was more necessary than
I imagined,” He said.
Occasionally, as we walked, we’d see blobs
watching us from crevices and dark alleys
on the side of the road.
They seemed to watch, but, for some reason,
didn’t approach.
It was the most remarkable thing.
“Don’t worry,” He told us.
“I’m putting up invisible shields.
None of them can approach us as long as I
maintain my focus.”
Of course, we’d all heard stories of remarkable
and terrifying things wandering the wasteland
we used to call planet earth.
You couldn’t run into other survivors and
groups without hearing whispers about the
things lurking out there.
Some had told of a giant, monstrous reptile
that had destroyed an entire survivor settlement
in a mall out in Nevada.
Others told that one of those SCP Sites was
haunted.
People spoke about a ghostly man who looked
like a rotten corpse, who could walk through
walls and drag people to Hell.
But the things Matthew was capable of seemed
to be a whole other level.
I asked Him what He was, and He told me, “Just
a humble craftsman, my son.
I enjoy creating, though admittedly, my creations
seem to have gotten away from me these days.”
His evasion was less funny than He seemed
to think it was.
I pressed on, asking Him what exactly he’s
capable of.
He shrugged, and answered that he could do
almost anything if he really put his mind
to it.
I asked, “So...
Ultimate power?”
This gave Him a chuckle.
He shook His head, and said, “Let me tell
you a story.
A man comes upon a maze cut into a corn field,
and decides he wants to try his luck.
He spends hours getting to the center of the
maze, and there, he finds the Devil waiting
for him.
The Devil says, ‘Welcome to my domain.
Your soul is now forfeit, unless you can complete
my challenge and win it back.’
Of course, the man agreed.
The Devil said, ‘I can see everything, do
everything, and be everything.
I know every inch of the universe and can
produce anything from thin air.
If you want to keep your soul, name one thing
I can’t do.”
Curious, I asked, “What did the man say?”
Matthew smiled and said, “Get lost.”
And for the first time in those long, dark
months, I actually laughed, and it was at
such a stupid, corny dad joke.
It’s a strange world we live in.
“Point is,” Matthew continued.
“There is no ‘Ultimate Power.’
Some things are denied even to God, especially
when he chooses to walk as a man on the Earth
he created.”
We kept walking for hours.
Matthew assured us that we would get there
in time, as the rest of us got ever more anxious
about the thought of the rising sun.
He said he’d seen so many sunrises now that
he could time them to the second.
In the meantime, we should enjoy getting to
stretch our legs a little.
Even now, the city could be beautiful at night.
When He led us all the way to what seemed
like an abandoned chemical plant, I could
feel my heart sink.
All this time, all this work, to find more
people, to find safety, only to see that this
place was abandoned, too.
Matthew smiled, and said, “That’s just
what they want you to think.”
He snapped his fingers and the ground around
us began to rumble.
The concrete shifted seamlessly and an entrance
opened up below.
Heavy bulkheads shifted, revealing a sleek,
chrome hallway down into the ground.
We were astonished.
Matthew gestured down into the hall and we
descended.
Matthew followed us, the entrance closing
behind him.
“I’m just warning you,” He said, “This
may come as a bit of a shock.”
We ventured deeper, passing through different
automated security checkpoints as cameras
gazed down from above.
Eventually, we found ourselves in what seemed
to be a central chamber.
It was a hive of activity.
People in normal civilians clothes.
Guards in tactical gear.
Scientists in lab coats.
Tears filled my eyes, it was the most people
I’d seen in one place in months.
A man in a lab coat wearing an extravagant
medallion approached.
He was making notes on a clipboard.
“Another batch of survivors.
Good work, 343,” the man said.
Matthew smiled and nodded.
“No problem, Jack.
Always happy to help.”
The man with the medallion - Jack, presumably
- turned to me.
“I imagine you’ve come a long way,”
he said.
I nodded.
“You have no idea.”
Reality warpers.
Real pieces of work, aren’t they?
It’s one thing when an anomaly is all claws
and fangs, like SCP-682, or if their attack
of choice is snapping necks like SCP-173,
but it’s an entirely different story if
an anomaly can turn the air you breathe into
chocolate pudding or shove you into a pocket
dimension that looks almost like our own reality,
except everyone is just a walking, talking
pile of spiders.
See what I mean?
Reality warpers, real handfuls.
Though, of course, not all reality warpers
are created equal.
Some are relatively weak, only affecting the
world around them in a mild, ambient fashion.
Others can rattle whole dimensions with their
tremendous power.
The same also goes for morality.
Some reality warpers are loving and benevolent,
such as SCP-343, the kindly, old all-powerful
being known to some as God.
And some are pure evil beings who want nothing
more than to use their immense power to sow
chaos and misery among everyone else.
And personally, we can’t think of a better
example of the latter than Bill Cipher from
Gravity Falls.
This Demonic Dorito wants nothing more than
to take over our dimension and rebuild it
in his image of absolute insanity.
So naturally, we started wondering: If these
two reality-warping titans, SCP-343 and Bill
Cipher, ever came to blows, who would win?
We were so curious, In fact, that we fired
up the Anom-O-Tron 6000, our state-of-the-art
simulation supercomputer, to see how exactly
the two might meet and how their epic battle
would play out.
Who do you think would take the coveted W
on this one?
Let us know down in the comments, along with
any other out of universe What If situations
you’d love to see.
But in the meantime, let’s fire up the machine.
Be warned, folks: It’s gonna get weird.
The date was July 12th, 2013.
For SCP-343, it had started out as a relatively
normal day.
He’d spent the night playing solitaire on
the astral plane, before warping back into
his humanoid containment cell by morning,
leaving the Foundation none the wiser.
After all, he was really here voluntarily.
If the Foundation had truly wanted to try
to confine him here, they were welcome to
give it a go, but it would be about as effective
as trying to catch a whisper in a butterfly
net.
While God had come to this place to experience
the joyful illusion of giving up control,
it truly was little more than an illusion
to him.
If he wanted to, he could exterminate the
SCP Foundation in less than an afternoon,
then retire to Burger King for a Whopper.
So really, they’re all just lucky he’s
a benevolent being, more interested in hanging
out than dispensing wrath on those he perceived
as insolent.
That was the Old Testament him.
He’d done a lot of soul searching and growth
since then.
It’d been at least a millennium since he’d
smote anyone, for that matter, and the last
guy really had it coming.
However, today was going to be a little different.
God knew that something was going to happen
today.
He sensed a great source of energy emerging.
Something dark and malevolent.
He sighed and closed his eyes for a moment,
focusing himself.
He knew, whatever the nature of this threat,
it would fall upon him to face and destroy
it.
How irritating.
He was hoping to finally binge Stranger Things
Season 4 today...
Elsewhere in Site 19, things seemed to be
inordinately peaceful.
There hadn’t been any containment breaches
or new anomalies brought in.
There hadn’t been any attacks from rival
Groups of Interest.
Dr. Bright hadn’t even done anything stupid
or started any fires.
To borrow an old cliché, it was quiet.
Too quiet.
Perhaps the only person who wasn’t having
a relatively mellow day was Security Officer
Frederick Simmons, a mid-level guard who’d
been stationed at Site 19 for four years now.
He just wasn’t feeling himself today...
The work didn’t bother Simmons - emotionally,
at least.
Typically, even after seeing rather traumatic
things or being in near-death situations while
in containment breaches, it hadn’t left
any lingering effects.
But lately, he’d been having the strangest
dreams...
It always played out the same way.
Shortly after going to sleep, he’d open
his eyes in a strange, multi-colored void,
surrounded by bizarre, seemingly random floating
objects, none of which seemed to have any
real relevance to him or his life.
And just when he’d begin to question it,
the other recurring element of the dream would
occur.
Out of the shimmering, oil-slick rainbow of
mind-boggling colors, a strange being would
suddenly emerge.
A glowing golden triangle, almost like a drawing
of a pyramid, with a stove pipe hat, a little
bow tie, thin black arms and legs, and most
notable of all, a single large eye with a
slit pupil staring out from the center.
The eye almost seemed to have a strange, hypnotic
quality to it.
Simmons felt bewitched whenever he looked
into it.
He wasn’t afraid.
Quite the opposite, actually.
For reasons he couldn’t understand, this
strange creature from the world of dreams
seemed like a good friend of his.
He said, “Well, well, well, well, if it
isn’t my number one guy, the Fredmeister,
in the house!
I’ve missed you.
Have you missed me?
Put her there, good buddy!”
The entity extended his hand, and Simmons
shook it.
The Foundation guard could feel a strange
tingling sensation jolting down his arm.
The first time Simmons had encountered the
entity, he’d told him his name: Bill Cipher,
and he’d told him how incredibly important
it was that Simmons kept their little nighttime
meetings a secret.
In exchange, Bill was here to listen.
Simmons would spend his time in the mindscape
pouring out his worries and frustrations with
his daily work, as Bill paid impeccable attention.
The strange little dream entity seemed fascinated
by the work Simmons did - All the peculiar
and wondrous anomalies he guarded at Site
19.
But to Simmons, it was all just boring work.
Zombie-creating supernatural plague doctors
and immortal men with metal limbs lose their
shine after you see them day in, day out,
for years on end.
Frankly, Simmons needed a day off, but he’d
already used up all his PTO when he’d gotten
the flu earlier that year.
He just didn’t know what to do.
Luckily for him, Bill had a solution.
Bill, as it turned out, had a fancy little
ability: He could occupy the body of a human
being, and operate it for them.
Bill could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape.
How hard could standing around, pretending
to look busy at the SCP Foundation really
be?
As Bill explained the offer to him, Simmons
couldn’t see any flaws in his reasoning
- After all, Bill was a friend.
Why would he have any ill will towards him?
With that, he shook hands with the bizarre
supernatural triangle, and felt the sudden,
rough sensation of having his consciousness
ripped free from his body, only for Bill to
slither in and take his place.
This new Simmons - The Bill-occupied Simmons
- opened up his demonic, yellow eyes, and
grinned.
He gave a demented laugh to Simmons’ floated,
disembodied soul.
“Oh man,” he said, wiping away a tear
of laughter with Simmons’ finger.
“That was too easy!
With your body, I can use the SCP Foundation’s
technology to take over the multiverse!
See ya, sucker!”
And with one last demented chuckle, Bill left
for work at the SCP Foundation, with Simmons
being the latest in his long line of meat
puppets.
After arriving at Site 19, he sneaked through
the facility, knowing exactly where he needed
to be.
You see, Bill is a native entity of the second
dimension - the world of flat shapes - but
he’s able to access the minds of beings
in the third dimension, like us, through the
medium of the mindscape, rather than the physical
realm.
Bill’s life goal has always been to find
a way to permeate and take over the third
dimension, turning it into his personal playground.
All he needed was the right anomaly to bring
him forth into our world.
In this case, a little anomalous device favored
by Dr. Kain Pathos Crow: SCP-158, also known
as The Soul Extractor.
While Dr. Crow left to the courtyard for his
evening walkies, the being that most people
assumed was Fred Simmons secreted himself
into SCP-158’s containment chamber and locked
the door behind him.
He didn’t have much time; he’d need to
do this perfectly if he wanted a real chance
at taking over the universe.
He was amused by the irony, at least.
The fact that, in order to take over, he’d
need to sneak into the midst of the people
most likely to destroy him.
Still, where’s the fun in a life with no
risk?
At SCP-158’s control console, he inputted
the data to soul extraction and set a timer.
However, there was one difference between
this and the usual procedures performed with
the Soul Extractor: There was no containment
receptacle on the other end.
Whatever was extracted would just be released
into the world.
And this was exactly what Bill was counting
on.
He laid Simmons’ body down on the gurney
and watched with glee as the robotic arm lowered
towards him.
It reached into his chest and pulled out the
essence of one three-sided threat to reality:
Bill Cipher.
One quick journey through the bowels of the
machine later, the nightmare scenario had
come to pass - Bill floated around the room,
dragged into physical reality.
He let out a long, conceited cackle and spun
his cane around.
This was going to be fun!
Elsewhere in the facility, alarms were going
off, and guards were deploying.
Nobody was meant to be in containment chamber
158, so how was the soul extractor currently
operating?
This couldn’t possibly end well...
Bill, on the other hand, was having a wonderful
time.
He was pondering all the different ways he
could make the drab, clinical corridors of
the SCP Foundation into his vision of perfect
weirdness.
Maybe he’d turn all the researchers into
mice and turn Site 19 into a giant maze to
run them through.
Maybe he’d turn the air into farts and release
winged beasts from the hell dimension to ravage
humanity.
Maybe he’d go out to the parking lot and
key everyone’s cars.
Oh, the diabolical possibilities were endless!
As he floated out into the hall, his fantasizing
was interrupted by a group of Foundation Security
Operatives wielding assault rifles.
They entered an attack formation and trained
their rifles on him, before opening fire.
Bill just found himself laughing again - The
gunfire just tickled!
“Wow, you guys are hilarious!”
Bill said between peals of laughter.
“But wait, I can think of a way to make
you even funnier!”
He snapped his fingers, and suddenly, the
guards were transformed.
Instead of the serious first line of defense
for the SCP Foundation, they were now a gang
of literal clowns straight from the circus,
holding balloon animals molded into the shapes
of assault rifles.
They giggled and threw pies at each other.
Bill was right; this did make them even funnier.
And he was just getting started, turning this
Foundation snoozefest into a party of cosmic
proportions!
Bill began running a rampage of weirdness
across the site.
Essentially being the ultimate cosmic troll,
he decided he’d simply bother every single
anomaly he could with his demonic antics.
First, he appeared in SCP-096’s chamber
and pulled a brown paper bag over his head,
with the words “UGLINESS LIES WITHIN”
written on the front.
And just for fun, he then teleported the temperamental
beast to a nearby Amish community.
It quickly became enraged when a gust of wind
blew the bag off its head, and a man named
Jedediah saw its face.
It then killed several others, also named
Jedediah, during the rampage.
Bill thought it was hilarious.
He then released SCP-682 into Site 19 and,
just to annoy the creature into further violence,
he stuck an indestructible party hat on the
monster’s head.
No matter how hard 682 tried, it couldn’t
remove the party hat.
This caused it great frustration, which it
took out on any Foundation staff it happened
to find in the area.
It had fulfilled Bill’s expectations wonderfully,
but his quest for amusing carnage didn’t
end there.
Next, he went to bother SCP-049, the Plague
Doctor, who was in the process of doing surgery
on a Foundation-provided dead goat.
With a snap of his fingers, Bill transformed
the Plague Doctor’s surgical tools into
colorful Play-Doh cutting tools.
Needless to say, the supernatural surgeon
was less than pleased.
He was about as annoyed as Dr. Clef was when
Bill turned his favorite shotgun into a bouquet
of flowers, then sealed his feet into the
floor, or how vexed Dr. Gears was when Bill
turned his plain beige necktie into a considerably
more loud and colorful tie.
People there at the time reported hearing
Dr. Gears say, “I just don’t think that
was necessary.”
Oh, and he also did some more minor acts of
malice: He filled the break room with an army
of flesh-eating zombies, he made a moat filled
with molten lava around the site that prevented
anyone from escaping from his reign of terror,
and he even covered all the walls in cognitohazardous
doodles that instantly drove any weak-minded
human who saw them into complete, gibbering
madness.
It was clear this reality-warping nightmare
needed to be stopped before he got bored of
playing with his new Foundation toys and decided
to go remodel the universe in his own image.
Thankfully, there was one anomaly on site
who was up to the task.
Bill was treating himself to another evil
laugh in the Site 19 canteen when something
peculiar happened.
He looked down to see a man in what looked
like a tunic with greying hair and a beard.
He walked with a peculiar kind of calmness,
his face blank.
Why wasn’t this guy panicking?
Was he stupid?
Bill would seemingly need to teach this guy
a thing or two about fear...
“Hey, gramps, don’t know if it’s escaped
your attention, but I’ve been giving this
place an extreme makeover!”
Bill yelled.
“Did you forget to put on your glasses this
morning, or are you just that senile?”
The stranger remained calm as could be.
He replied with a voice that was measured
as it was deep, “Now, Bill, let’s not
resort to name calling.
That’s just childish, don’t you think?”
Bill’s single eye widened at this.
“Wait, Wait, hold up.
How do you know my name?”
Bill asked, irritated.
“Are you a friend of the Time Baby or something?”
He floated over and began circling the stranger,
hoping to intimidate him.
Much to Bill’s frustration, it didn’t
appear to be working.
“I know lots of things, Bill, lots of things,”
the stranger replied.
“That’s my line!”
Bill screeched, turning red.
“Who do you think you are?”
The stranger gave a quiet, reserved chuckle
that infuriated Bill.
“Oh, personally, I just like to think of
myself as a humble craftsman, watching his
beautiful creation play out,” he said.
“But I suppose some of the people around
here like to call me God.”
Bill didn’t like this.
This whole universe was going to be his, and
he certainly didn’t appreciate some insolent
old man acting like he ran the roost around
here.
Bill would give him an education in who was
really holding the reins - and it would be
the kind of education that left scars, if
it left anything at all.
He extended his spindly black arms and released
bolts of lightning against the stranger, who
simply continued to smile as the electricity
rippled around him, seemingly causing no effect.
“Are you done?”
the stranger asked.
Bill laughed, hoping to hide his irritation.
“I’m just getting started!”
He bellowed.
With a thunderous roar that shook the very
foundations of Site 19, Bill began to grow
and shift.
No longer a silly little triangle, he became
a huge, red pyramid of pure nightmares, covered
in glowing golden arms and teeth, with long,
black tongues drooping out of each level.
It was the most terrifying and demonic form
in his entire arsenal, and yet, he was astonished
to find that the stranger still didn’t seem
to show any kind of fear.
“Very impressive, Bill,” the stranger
said, sounding almost bored.
“But I think you might be trying a little
too hard.”
Oh, that does it; Bill would simply have to
destroy him.
It was a matter of pride now.
He raised several of his huge, golden fists
and began pounding down on the comparatively
tiny, humanoid stranger.
It was an assault so powerful that the ground
began cracking around their feet.
And yet, it seemed that with almost no effort,
the stranger was able to intercept and block
every single blow.
Naturally, Bill was infuriated.
It was time to finally unleash the full breadth
of his power on this beardy wise guy.
He launched thunderbolts, fireballs, legions
of giant, mutant wasps, hailstorms, maelstroms,
bubbles of pure madness, snakes made of barbed
wire, and even incredible coarse language.
But despite it all, this man - the one who
claimed people call him God - was utterly
unfazed.
“You can dish it out,” he said.
“But let’s see if you can take it.”
Bill began to laugh.
“What the heck is that supposed to mean?
You can’t—“
God snapped his fingers, and Bill was gone.
Vanished.
And with a flick of his wrist, all the damage
and transformations that Bill had performed
had disappeared.
It was as though the demonic triangle had
never even been there in the first place.
Though Dr. Bright, who was acting Site Director
at the time, had some Scranton Reality Anchors
turned on around the perimeter, just to be
safe.
You can never be too careful with reality-warping
demons, after all.
Later that day, Dr. Bright approached God,
and asked him what he’d actually done with
Bill.
God chuckled and replied, “For a being of
such immense power, he really had a rather
childish mindset, so I sealed him away inside
a children’s cartoon, where he couldn’t
do any further damage.”
“What was the cartoon?”
Dr. Bright asked.
“A charming little Disney show called Gravity
Falls,” God replied.
Addiction.
It takes many forms and wears many faces,
like a demon walking among us.
It takes over your life - crawling in and
changing you from the inside out.
Breaking an addiction is hard, but oftentimes
not giving it up is much harder.
That was a difficult lesson to learn for three
people: Joey Walker, Dolly McGregor, and Paul
Ables.
These three had never met one another, and
now, they never will, but each of them had
two things in common.
First was that they each had an addiction
they felt like they couldn’t shake, and
the second was that they each had a run-in
with SCP-666.
Joey Walker was at the end of his rope when
he encountered it.
Everyone has bad days, but for Joey, every
day for the last fifteen years has been a
bad day.
He was pushing 40 with nothing to show for
it, except credit card debt, a scraggly beard,
and a beat-up old Mustang.
But booze had always been there for him.
No matter how bad things got, he could always
count on a glass full of comfort at the end
of the day.
But to paraphrase a quote by Stephen King,
“Sometimes, when a man takes a drink, the
drink takes the man.”
And Joey Walker had been long since taken.
He was a transient worker, doing jobs wherever
jobs needed doing, but he never expected that
he would end up all the way to Tibet working
construction.
Not that he was complaining - Sure, it was
cold, but there was plenty of Tibetan Chang
to enjoy.
It was a drink so good that legends even say
that Yetis would raid villages in the mountains
to get a little taste.
Joey had taken a liking to the Chang, and
it was what he had been drinking when he crashed
his car up in the mountains, leaving him stranded
in the snow.
Joey had survived the crash itself, but he
knew he wouldn’t last long in the cold.
He needed shelter.
That’s why he felt like he could hardly
believe his luck when he first saw the Yurt
- a kind of traditional, Tibetan tent made
from animal skins.
Joey had never seen anything quite like it,
but any refuge from the storm would do.
He pushed forward through the snow and climbed
inside.
But the inside of the Yurt was nothing like
the outside.
In fact, it seemed like an exact replica of
his favorite sports bar back in Atlantic City.
It was warm, there was all the old memorabilia
on the walls, and every screen was showing
the Saints wiping the floor with the Colts
in the 2010 Superbowl.
Joey didn’t even question it.
He just smiled, and approached the bar.
He even recognized the bartender - Malcolm,
a good old friend of his.
Malcolm smiled back at him, but there was
something oddly menacing in his grin.
“Welcome back,” he said.
“I thought you’d hauled your sorry keister
off to Tibet.
Guess you gave up on that too, just like everything
else.
Well, except…”
Malcolm pushed a glass of beer towards him
across the bar, and glared.
Joey didn’t understand why Malcolm was being
so aggressive, but he didn’t question that,
either.
He grabbed the glass and drank up, guzzling
it down before slamming the empty glass down
on the bar.
Malcolm kept the drinks coming, round after
round after round, and Joey kept knocking
them back.
He didn’t notice when the TV screens turned
to static.
He didn’t notice when the other patrons
at the bar began to jitter and twitch, turning,
little by little, into something less than
human.
He didn’t even notice when Malcolm’s face
started melting off his skull, as long as
he kept pouring.
Before he could even really understand what
was happening to him, Joey Walker was dead.
His liver and kidneys had given out on him.
His corpse would later be found, frozen on
the Tibetan mountainside, just thirty feet
away from his crashed car.
The coroner’s report would list his cause
of death as, “Accidental.”
But this was no accident.
He’d fallen victim to SCP-666, an anomalous
Yurt known to some as the Spirit House.
The being he’d called Malcolm is known to
the Foundation as SCP-666-1, and Malcolm had
failed its challenge.
Sadly for our inebriated friend, the penalty
for failure is death.
Next on our list of human tragedies comes
Dolly McGregor, a 62-year-old woman from Anaheim,
California.
Dolly was never averse to the drink, but she
knew how to enjoy her Mojitos in moderation.
You rarely get to 62 if you don’t, and Dolly
could tell people with pride that she had
two children, and six grandchildren, whom
she didn’t see nearly often enough for her
liking.
She also had over $100,000 in gambling debt
owed to a number of Casinos on the Vegas Strip.
Ever since her husband, Albert, had passed
away several years prior, shooting craps,
playing blackjack, and whiling away the hours
in front of the slot machines had been a welcome
change from loneliness.
But in Vegas, fortunes can change in an instant
- Dolly had gone from being on a hot winning
streak to losing everything.
The casinos extended her lines of credit until
she was gambling with money she’d never
be able to pay back, but that didn’t stop
her.
She’d been selling off everything, even
remortgaging the house that Albert had built
with his own two hands to try and keep up
with her ballooning debts.
Still, it wasn’t enough, but she couldn’t
stop, either.
It wasn’t even that she felt good about
it anymore, it was just that she only ever
felt normal among the flashing lights of slot
machines and the clatter of dice.
She needed to get away; as far away as possible.
She’d heard about people reaching spiritual
enlightenment in Tibet.
They’d discovered God, or Gods, or sometimes
just a sense of inner peace.
Whatever it was, she needed to find it and
to get this demon off her back.
So she took the last of her savings and flew
off to Tibet to clear her head.
She didn’t know if there were any casinos
in Lhasa, but if there were, her money would
surely be no good there.
It was exactly what she needed.
But Tibet wasn’t the promised land she thought
it would be.
Wherever Dolly went, there she was, with the
same vices and demons chasing her.
The first night she spent in Lhasa, she used
the hotel wifi to download an online poker
app on her phone.
This culminated in another couple thousand
dollars lost, and a panic attack that caused
Dolly to throw her phone into her toilet before
wandering off into the wilderness.
She just needed to get away.
But time and space got away from her, and
eventually, she was knee deep in the snow.
Where had she come from?
Where could she go?
It quickly dawned on her that, if she didn’t
find some kind of shelter soon, she’d be
done for.
But all she could do was keep walking…
That’s when she happened upon SCP-666.
The Yurt was like an oasis on the barren mountainside.
She didn’t expect comfort inside, but it
could at least provide her some shelter until
the staff back at the hotel noticed she was
gone.
Then they’d come and save her, right?
Right?
But when she passed through the yak-leather
flap into the Yurt, Dolly wasn’t in an ancient
tent in the Tibetan wilderness, she was on
a casino floor.
There was a big, beautiful roulette table
before her, attended to by a grinning, well-dressed
croupier.
They were flanked by an army of slot machines,
and all the pleasing, familiar sounds of cheerful
gambling rang out through the air.
She approached the table, and the croupier
shook his head in what seemed like disappointment.
“Back again, eh, Dolly?” he said with
a sigh.
“Of course, I should have expected it.
After all, what else do you have in that empty
little life of yours, hmm?
Without all this, you’d be nothing, right?
Nothing at all.
Since Albert died and the kids want nothing
to do with you, we’re all you’ve got.
So, Dolly, what’ll it be - Red or black?
Are you feeling lucky?”
His words wounded Dolly, but that wouldn’t
stop her.
She grabbed her chips, and put them all on
red.
One last spin couldn’t hurt.
What did she have to lose?
She blinked, and she wasn’t sitting at the
table anymore.
She was upright, but she wasn’t standing.
Her wrists and ankles were bound to something
- to a wheel, a giant roulette wheel, like
it was some medieval torture device.
The croupier was standing across from her.
Well, something that used to be a croupier.
His face was flickering in and out; sometimes
it was human, sometimes it was a mess of eyes
and teeth.
More demons were sitting at all the slot machines
behind him, pulling levers made from human
bones.
“Good choice, Dolly,” the croupier said.
“Red suits you.”
He reached out and gave the wheel a spin.
Dolly was lost in an overwhelming, pulsing
cascade of lights, colors, and sounds.
The horrific, tinny noises of slot machines
and the laughter of the demonic croupier.
She was lost in panic and terror as she just
kept spinning, and spinning, and spinning…
When her body was eventually found, her muscles
were in the advanced stages of atrophy, as
though she hadn’t been moving for years.
Her brain was rotted, and the cause of death
was determined as sudden cardiac arrest after
an extended period of sleep-deprivation and
malnutrition.
Dolly’s family would never really know what
happened to her.
The SCP Foundation had learned a lot about
SCP-666 after containing it in Site 73.
Its anomalous effects namely, vivid, complex,
and potentially fatal hallucinatory experiences
only affect those with some kind of addiction
or dependency.
To anyone else entering the Yurt, it’s just
a normal tent.
But any addicts who enter will fall under
its spell, and are generally transported back
to the place they were when their addiction
was at its strongest.
There, they’ll encounter SCP-666-1, an entity
that takes the form of a figure from the subject’s
life - normally one heavily involved in facilitating
their addiction.
Any kind of addiction seems to trigger it
- alcohol, drugs, gambling, pornography, food,
self-destructive behavior, even video games.
SCP-666 kills its victims with a twisted mockery
of the very thing they were dependent on in
life.
It was only with Paul Ables that the Foundation
started discovering the other side of the
coin.
By almost all accounts, Paul is a worse person
than anyone on this list.
He got addicted to hard drugs early on in
life, and took up a life of violent crime
to support his habit.
He murdered two people during a liquor store
robbery, before being convicted and sentenced
to death.
He’d then been picked up as a D-Class by
the SCP Foundation, and selected as a test
subject for SCP-666 due to his history of
drug abuse.
The Foundation expected to be adding his body
to the incineration pile sometime soon.
None of the researchers working on the case
predicted what actually ended up happening.
Paul was forced to enter the Yurt.
Not long after, he found himself standing
in a place he’d done everything to try to
forget: The dark, graffiti-stained alley where
he’d been sold his first hit.
This was the place.
The place that destroyed his life.
Every bad decision he’d ever made could
be traced back to here.
And specifically to one man…
Frank.
Frank was his first dealer, and how here he
was, standing right across from him once more.
Frank was grinning like a demon.
“C’mon, Paulie,” he said.
“You’re gutter trash.
We both know what you’re going to do.
Don’t you feel it?
The itch?
One more hit, Paulie, that’s all you need
to feel better.
It’s time to take your medicine…”
Frank - or this thing, pretending to be Frank
- was right.
He did feel the itch.
He did want it.
Maybe he was no better than this.
He began to reach out towards Frank, but then
he abruptly pulled his hand back.
Frank’s eyes widened in genuine surprise,
as Paul replied, “I’m sorry.
That’s not me anymore.”
SCP-666-1 gave a smile, and said, “Maybe
it isn’t, Paulie, maybe it isn’t…”
When Paul Ables was removed from the SCP-666
Yurt by one of the attending guards, the Foundation
researchers discovered something amazing.
Paul was very much alive, and more incredibly,
he didn’t feel the cravings anymore.
His addiction was gone.
And further tests showed that Paul wasn’t
a one-off event.In fact, anyone who denies
the temptation of SCP-666 will see their addictions
miraculously disappear when they finally leave.
After this it became clear to the Foundation
that SCP-666 isn’t just a way to punish
addicts, it’s a kind of test.
Those who want to change, who are willing
to truly confront their demons and resist
the pull of temptation are rewarded with the
one thing they want most in life, freedom
from their addiction.
SCP-666 can be your doom or your salvation.
And like most things in life, you get what
you give.
One fine morning, your distant Aunt Carol
came to your family home in an almost frantic
state of excitement.
Carol had always been a bit eccentric, totally
harmless, of course, but what you’d describe
as being on the more “zealous” side of
religious.
Predictably, she wanted to ask you and your
family to come to church with her.
Seeing as you don’t see Aunt Carol often,
you and your family decide that there’s
no harm in indulging her.
You’re not an atheist family by any means,
in fact you were all raised Catholic, but
it felt like it’d been forever since you
last went to church.
Aunt Carol wanted to show you and your family
the special celebrations that went on at her
church.
You remember her practically grabbing you
by the wrist and dragging you to the building,
her eyes filled with a crazed enthusiasm.
That’s when you saw something incredibly
strange, there were shadows moving behind
the elaborate stained glass windows.
Thousands of tiny shadows, darting around.
And this low humming noise you faintly recognized.
What was that noise?
It was the cry of cicadas, but this was only
early spring.
What were cicadas doing awake at this time
of year?
You didn’t get much time to ponder this
question.
In the next few seconds, you and the entire
church were surrounded by heavy duty tactical
vehicles.
What appeared to be a large and heavily-armed
SWAT team poured out of the vehicles.
Unbeknownst to you, these were a Mobile Task
Force sent in by the SCP Foundation.
Specifically, MTF Y-99, also known as the
Altar Boys, a specially trained group of Foundation
agents used for anomalies of a religious nature.
You, your Aunt, and the rest of your family
are rounded up to be debriefed and given amnestics.
One of the last memories they took from you
was the sight of Foundation Agents dragging
bloodied bodies out of the church.
As the doors opened, thousands of cicadas
streamed out and dispersed into the skies.
But these weren’t like any kind of cicada
you’d never seen, they were beautiful, their
rainbow-colored wings reminding you of ornate
stained glass.
Who could have guessed that these pretty little
bugs are tied to an entity very likely to
bring about an XK-Class End of the World Scenario
some day in the future?
The bugs, the bodies in the church, and even
your aunt’s incredibly strange behavior
all fall under the umbrella of a Keter-Class
anomaly known as SCP-3004.
But to truly understand this anomaly that
was once thought to be destroyed, and the
implications of it still living today, we
need to go back 600 years, to Ireland in the
15th Century.
This era was believed to be the origin of
a Gaelic religious movement known as “Cétlaidí”,
or the “The Singers” in English, a splinter
sect of Druidism.
But this was no fringe cult, The Singers were
a mainstream religion in the British Isles
for several hundred years.
Its members included people of all social
classes, from lowly peasants to powerful and
respected figures.
They mingled heavily with Christians, mostly
Irish Catholics, and at some points in history
came close to overtaking Christianity as the
dominant religion in Ireland.
So, who were these people, if they’re supposedly
such a large part of recent history in the
area?
Like most Druids, their relationship with
nature was a key part of their belief system.
In particular, they prized an extinct species
of Cicada known as Cicadetta luculenta, or
the “stained glass cicada”, in English.
The life cycle of birth and resurrection that
the cicadas underwent fascinated the Singers,
and they performed a number of holy rituals
around it.
One recorded ritual was the celebration of
children entering adulthood that was marked
by them first losing their baby teeth.
But the rituals of the Singers accidentally
opened some kind of door to a being from a
different plane of reality, dubbed SCP-3004-1
by the Foundation.
This being is an immensely powerful thought-form
that the Foundation believes to be a “Pistiphage”,
or “Faith Eater.”
It appears to have been attracted to our universe
by the rituals of the Singers, and so took
a form relevant to their beliefs, namely,
a huge cicada, in order to feed on their faith.
If things had stopped there then this would
be an almost innocent symbiotic relationship,
but the interactions between SCP-3004-1 and
our world led to dangerous consequences due
to its powerful reality-warping abilities.
For example, during some rituals, huge numbers
of stained glass cicadas would burst from
the mouths of those participating, often causing
them to choke to death.
Other times 3004-1 would manifest physically
in the sky above its new worshippers, causing
painful boils on whoever witnessed it, and
occasionally symptoms akin to radiation sickness.
It appeared that 3004-1 was growing more powerful
over time, and its rise to power was intrinsically
linked to the rituals of the Singers and the
existence of the stained glass cicadas.
Two groups that pre-dated the Foundation,
the Vatican’s “Congregation for Otherworldly
Acts” and the English Government’s “Royal
Society for the Imprisonment of Abnormalcy”,
essentially performed an all-out religious
genocide on the Singers.
No meaningful trace of the religion was left
when they were done, aside from their own
records.
While they were at it, they also exterminated
all the stained glass cicadas, leading to
a complete stop of all SCP-3004 activity.
It seemed like, despite the great human and
ecological cost, the anomaly had been neutralized.
A few centuries later though, a series of
strange, cicada-related anomalous events started
to occur across the United States.
A strange man, seemingly made almost entirely
from cicada chitin, would appear at christenings,
weddings, and funerals.
Each time, his presence would cause the people
in attendance to do and experience horrific
things and lead to legacies of hardship and
death that would linger for decades.
This became known as SCP-2852, or “Cousin
Johnny” and it should have been the first
clue that the nightmare of SCP-3004 was resurfacing.
But since 3004 was already archived as “neutralized”,
nobody made the connection.
Some time later, SCP-2852 incidents ceased,
and around that exact time, SCP-3004 instances
started anew.
It manifested in the form of strange, anomalous
activities taking place at Christian church
services, specifically, those from Roman Catholic,
Eastern Catholic, Anglican, and Episcopalian
communities.
The only clues to outsiders would be an increase
in reported church attendance, and an increase
in deaths from “natural causes” within
the community.
These two stats were how the Foundation first
noticed something was amiss.
Just as it had done with the Singers centuries
before, SCP-3004-1 had latched onto the beliefs
and rituals of Christians, and was using this
new connection to harvest more faith for sustenance.
The results were twofold.
First, religious fervor and excitement to
attend church services saw a huge increase.
Secondly, the actual content of these services
took a hard turn for the horrific.
Much like Cousin Johnny infiltrations, this
really isn’t for the faint of heart by any
definition.
For example, young people with Christ-like
stigmata wounds being bitten to death by priests.
Children removing the teeth of priests, before
they all start vomiting huge numbers of stained
glass cicadas.
There were extremely unpleasant rituals involving
castration and even a pregnant woman giving
birth to even more swarms of stained glass
cicadas.
We could go on, but you probably get the idea.
Rituals inspired by SCP-3004-1 are horrific,
and all seem to involve the same extinct breed
of stained glass cicadas worshipped by the
Singers before their annihilation.
But how can these insects, which have been
dubbed SCP-3004-2, be here in the present
if the Foundation forerunners made them extinct
so many centuries ago?
The answer is simple, but strange.
While they have all the hallmarks of being
alive, the stained glass cicadas present during
modern iterations of SCP-3004 events aren’t
actually real.
Genetic tests have shown that they’re actually
made from a mix of wood and real stained glass.
These insects fly away from the scene after
the rituals are completed, traveling around
six hundred miles from the site before disappearing
completely.
The Foundation was growing concerned about
the nature of SCP-3004, especially given that
instances were becoming more frequent and
harder to contain.
Foundation scientists determined that the
creature known as 3004-1 likely existed within
a layer of reality just above our own, and
if it ever managed to breach our reality,
the worldwide level of violence and chaos
it could cause would likely lead to an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario.
Drastic actions would once again be needed
to prevent this, so they devised an emergency
containment procedure that would only be used
as a last resort.
The procedure, known as Protocol Damnatio
ad Bestias, would use a mixture of mass amnestic
treatment and Thaumiel objects to completely
erase Christianity from not only the modern
world, but all of history in the hopes of
cutting off 3004-1’s food supply to kill
the entity or at least prevent it from entering
our world.
The plan would center on placing a powerful
Roman-Catholic reality warper, who volunteered
for the job of course, into an anomalous group
of machines known as “The Lions.”
By submitting the reality warper to a lifetime
of suffering and essentially erasing him from
existence, so too will it erase the world’s
full knowledge of Christianity, and hopefully
save the world.
This man will become the last martyr, dying
for all of humanity.
He will become the last saint, St. Jude the
Damned, Bulwark Against Darkness
You might ask: Are you sure this is necessary?
There’s so much we don’t know about 3004-1.
Do we know for a fact it’s this dangerous?
Enter Agent Timothy Luttermann, a member of
Mobile Task Force Sigma-25, also known as
“Ghostbusters.”
Luttermann was part of a Foundation project
known as SIGHTSEE-LUX, using an astral projection
technology that would free his consciousness
from his body, and allow it to travel freely
between metaphysical planes.
In plain English, they could use Luttermann’s
floating mind as a kind of spy, and insert
it into 3004-1’s dimension.
They achieved this by capturing one of 3004-1’s
false stained glass cicadas, and releasing
it again, allowing Luttermann’s mind to
follow it home to its master.
However, what was thought to be a simple intel
gathering mission turned into a complete nightmare.
Luttermann found that 3004-1’s dimension
was entirely void, aside from the entity itself,
and the millions of buzzing stained glass
cicadas.
The entity was so huge and so complex that
it physically hurt to look at.
Luttermann observed that its form kept shifting,
from a giant cicada, to an old man, to a cicada
nailed to a wooden cross, to an infinite mess
of wood and stained glass.
But even more terrifying than its physical
appearance were the contents of its mind.
3004-1 forced itself into Agent Luttermann’s
brain, and in that moment, he finally understood
it.
The entity, which had no concept of metaphors,
allegory, or the divide between fact and fiction,
truly believed that it was the Abrahamic God
depicted in the bible, and that all Christians
are lovingly worshipping it.
In its rituals, it was imposing some of the
bloodiest parts of the bible onto its flock,
believing that’s what they wanted.
All the while, it fed on their faith, growing
bigger and more powerful.
Luttermann found that just being there with
the creature was hurting his soul.
If it wasn’t a God yet, he believed it had
the power to become one in time and he advised
that the Foundation shouldn’t send anyone
else to its dimension.
It was too great a risk to all life on Earth.
Perhaps, to prevent the horrible fate of us
all being destroyed by 3004-1, erasing Christianity
would be a worthy sacrifice.
That is, if it actually works.
After all, they thought destroying the Singers
would neutralize 3004 once and for all, and
yet here it is again.
For all we know, we may just be prolonging
the inevitable...
If you ever studied Ancient Egypt in your
history class, then you are probably familiar
with the way they buried their pharaohs.
When a king of Egypt died, their body would
be entombed in a huge sarcophagus, usually
after being mummified.
Mummification was the process that the Ancient
Egyptians used to preserve their dead, safeguarding
a corpse with special chemicals and the application
of cloth, almost like bandages.
This was done to keep cadavers from decaying,
usually because of the belief that this would
carry over into the afterlife.
And it wasn’t just the Egyptians that practiced
mummification either, mummies of human beings
or animals have been found on almost every
continent in the world.
Sometimes, a body can even be accidentally
mummified, through exposure to extreme cold,
lack of oxygen or other environmental factors
that help keep the deceased preserved.
Fun fact, the oldest recorded mummy isn’t
even one left behind by the Ancient Egyptians.
It is actually a naturally mummified severed
head estimated to be 6000 years old.
It was unearthed in South America in 1936.
Yes, corpse preservation techniques can indeed
be strange, but none are stranger than SCP-1176,
also known by the nickname “The Mellified
Man.”
Now, as you may have already pieced together,
the Mellified Man is a mummified corpse, but
not quite like the ones you would expect to
find buried in the Pyramids.
Estimated by Foundation researchers to have
been a man in his mid-thirties when he died,
SCP-1176 is a corpse that has degraded so
much over the centuries that it has made DNA
examination impossible.
According to some of the SCP Foundation’s
best minds, SCP-1176 is possibly of Arabian
ancestry, and thought to have passed away
sometime during either the 10th or the 11th
centuries AD.
This is certainly not your ordinary mummy,
and it definitely isn’t like the kind you’d
see in a cheesy black and white horror movie
or an old episode of Scooby-Doo.
SCP-1176 is absolutely, undoubtedly dead by
all clinical definitions.
It doesn’t show any signs of breathing,
and the processes of blood circulation or
metabolism have long since stopped.
However, despite the decay suffered by the
rest of the body, SCP-1176’s brain seems
to have remained intact for almost ten whole
centuries.
Not just intact, but active.
The Foundation’s researchers have confirmed
that the brain has a constant level of electrical
activity, consistent with people experiencing
stage 3 non-rapid eye movement sleep, known
colloquially as “deep sleep.”
So, a mummy with an active, albeit dormant
brain.
How does an ancient culture manage to achieve
preservation like this?
Alien technology?
Cryogenic sleep chambers?
Suspended animation?
No, not quite, SCP-1176 exists in its current
state, in part, because the body has been
mellified.
Now, this was a process a lot like mummification,
but instead of wrapping them in cloth, a Mellified
Man or a “human mummy confection” was
created by submerging a dead body in honey.
According to historical records, elderly men
in Arabic countries would sometimes willingly
volunteer themselves for this process.
Why?
Because the goal was to turn their bodies
into a healing confection.
In other words, an elaborate sweet delicacy
created from a preserved corpse.
That’s right, ancient cultures had candy
made from dead people.
All the information the Foundation has gathered
about SCP-1176 seems to point to the body
being one such mellified man.
When extracting the remaining bodily fluids
from the corpse, instead of finding blood
and other normal substances, Foundation researchers
discovered that SCP-1176 was full of a viscous,
gold colored liquid that they designated as
SCP-1176-1.
Further testing of this fluid revealed it
to be, you guessed it, honey.
Specifically, it was a type known as clover
honey, made by a species called the Anatolian
honey bee.
This stuff was everywhere, filling SCP-1176
entirely, so much so that honey was even coming
out of the body’s pores.
This is due to the nature of the mellification
process.
Typically, before death, a person who had
offered to sacrifice their own body would
stop eating any food.
Instead, their diet would consist solely of
honey, and nothing else.
They would even bathe in it, submerging their
entire body in the substance inside and out
until their sweat, and even their feces were
pure honey.
This honey-only diet would eventually kill
the donor, and their corpse would be placed
in a stone coffin, which was also filled up
with even more honey.
After approximately one hundred years, what
would be left was human mummy confection,
a honey based candy of sorts, that could then
be sold at street markets for a high value
price.
Why was it so expensive?
Well, not just because it was literally made
from a dead person, but also because this
confection was believed to possess rare and
powerful healing properties.
Everything from the common cold to broken
bones was said to be cured by it.
Despite it leaking out of SCP-1176, the honey
doesn’t seem to ever run out, even when
tested under varying conditions.
It seems like the Mellified Man actively produces
more of the sweet, golden substance, acting
as the source rather than a container with
a finite amount.
And yes, it’s still edible after several
centuries.
In fact, it contains an abundance of essential
vitamins and nutrients.
According to the Foundation’s testing, the
honey produced by SCP-1176 can suppress the
feeling of hunger for up to eighteen whole
hours, and there are no long term side effects
for most that eat it.
However, this is not the case for everyone.
The Foundation has learned that any person
without the blood type AB+ will have a severe
allergic reaction should they consume any
of SCP-1176-1.
The symptoms include acute hemolysis, which
means the red blood cells won’t break down
properly, and renal failure, which is when
the kidneys stop functioning.
This all results in death for most of the
subjects without AB+ blood who were fed SCP-1176-1.
The symptoms for these unlucky people were
the same as receiving an incompatible blood
type after a transfusion.
In 1985, the SCP Foundation launched a raid
on a facility in Asmara, Eritrea, which at
the time was owned by a group called the Manna
Charitable Foundation.
Agents had been dispatched to this facility
after various rumors and reports that pointed
to this location being the source of a strange
honey substance.
This anomalous liquid was being shipped to
a number of areas in Ethiopia that had been
stricken with famine.
Pretty easy to guess where the Manna Charitable
Foundation got all that honey, right?
The problem was, because SCP-1176-1 caused
adverse effects on people without AB+ blood,
a considerable amount of civilians had died
from consuming it.
Hence, the SCP Foundation was forced to step
in.
When SCP-1176 was first uncovered, the body
had been stored inside a large stone sarcophagus,
as was part of the ancient practice of creating
a mellified man.
There was also a copper pipe and spigot, installed
by the Manna Charitable Foundation to extract
the honey from within.
The lid, sides and the inside of the sarcophagus
itself had a number of Egyptian hieroglyphics
inscribed within.
These were mostly spells and ceremonial texts,
written as a way to protect the individual
that was to become the Mellified Man.
There were also inscriptions written in a
dialect that was an early precursor to the
Arabic language, however these sections had
been replaced with updated versions in Classical
Arabic.
One of these read:
“Abdallah ibn Salah ibn Ayyub ibn Nasir,
fifteenth son of the great sheikh (illegible),
was put to the fast of honey on the first
of Rajab in the year of the Hijra 3(illegible),
and died on the fifteenth of Ramadan.
The great imam al-Yusuf has sealed him within
the ancient vessel, marked with the signs
decreed by the ancients, to ferment in honey
for one hundred years and bring aid to the
people in time of need.”
Much like a headstone used to mark the grave
of someone who has passed, the sarcophagus
that SCP-1176 was in featured a passage commemorating
a man who gave his life and body to heal others.
Sounds nice, right?
But there was another inscription, written
elsewhere on the stone sarcophagus, which
translated to a dire warning:
“Beware, imam, for the mark of Iblis is
upon this one!”
According to the rest of the second inscription,
the tomb containing SCP-1176 had been opened
before.
During a time of great famine, imam Al-Malik
had ordered it to be opened so that the SCP-1176-1
honey could be used to feed the starving people.
Jars upon jars were filled with the anomalous
golden liquid and brought to the sheikh, the
ruler of the land, as well as sent to the
people suffering from the lack of food.
However, the very next day a number of these
people fell ill, stricken by a terrible fever
that ultimately claimed their lives.
Only the sheikh, his brothers and his sons,
who had all eaten the honey, survived.
Any others who hadn’t been killed by the
fever accused the sheikh and his family of
sorcery, and these surviving subjects attempted
to destroy the body that had produced this
cursed nectar.
But when the sheikh’s people found the Mellified
Man, they witnessed in horror as the body
stood upright, dancing around as it screamed
and taunted the people.
Al-Malik declared that the Devil himself sent
an evil spirit to corrupt SCP-1176.
The honey confection was meant to be a means
of healing, but it had been corrupted.
The sarcophagus was then sealed, and the inscription
on it finished with the following caution
to any that found it:
“May God strike down any who would break
these seals.”
Countless centuries later, once the SCP Foundation
had recovered SCP-1176 and the sarcophagus
containing it, they began testing with the
Mellified Man.
Their goal was to determine how much of the
SCP-1176-1 honey the ancient corpse could
produce, perhaps in the hopes of using this
substance as a form of hunger relieving field
ration for their operatives.
Removing the body from its sarcophagus, Foundation
researchers placed SCP-1176 on a metal grate,
designed to drain the honey as it was produced
instead of allowing it to build up.
Over the course of several hours, more and
more honey seemed to be produced, beginning
at a rate of almost a liter per hour, to almost
56 liters every hour.
But then, after ten and a half hours of producing
what seemed like an endless flow of honey,
something unexpected happened.
The deceased body of the Mellified Man, dead
for hundreds if not thousands of years, woke
up.
Foundation staff detected a spike in brain
activity, if you cast your mind back to earlier,
you’ll remember that SCP-1176’s brain
had managed to survive and stay intact long
after it should have decayed.
The Mellified Man opened his eyes and immediately
started to wildly flail around.
He made a number of distressed sounds, the
long dead body trying to crawl towards the
outskirts of the testing chamber.
Thanks to so many of its organs and muscles
having withered away over the years, SCP-1176
was barely able to see or understand its surroundings.
It couldn’t speak, not properly anyway,
given that its tongue had long since decayed.
The Foundation’s personnel moved in to try
and restrain the ancient and now animated
body, hoping to sedate it before SCP-1176
caused any lasting damage to itself.
Eventually, staff were able to force SCP-1176
back into its sarcophagus, slamming the stone
lid back in place and trapping it within.
They could hear the once human creature screeching
and vocalizing from inside, bashing against
the inside of the stone coffin with its head
and limbs.
It took three whole hours of this for the
Mellified Man to return to its usual state,
by which time its ancient bones were fractured
beyond repair.
SCP-1176 is a sad tale of a man who had willingly
given his life to be a source of healing for
people in need.
He allowed himself to be mellified, turned
into a confection that could bring an end
to famine.
And yet, somehow, this was corrupted and turned
into something that spread fever and pestilence.
For now, the Mellified Man sleeps, but his
brain is still alive inside.
While he might be asleep, he may never be
able to rest.
In 1961, the SCP Foundation discovered a town
that was completely devoid of all life.
Not long before their arrival, Darrington,
North Carolina, had been a community with
high aspirations.
A deeply religious township of devout Christians,
many of whom were seeking greater prosperity
from their lives.
But now, their home was a ghost town, with
no sign of any prior Darrington resident to
be found.
Where the hell had they all gone?
It hardly seemed likely that the population
of an entire town would all simultaneously
decide to up sticks and leave to pastures
new.
But then again, maybe the citizens of Darrington
hadn’t left at all.
Perhaps they weren’t even really still human,
and had taken up residence somewhere much
darker…
like underground?
This is the story of one of the earliest known
instances of a phenomena now known under the
designation of SCP-3089, or to use its alternative
name: That Old Time Religion.
When the SCP Foundation arrived in a desolate
Darrington to find the townsfolk had all vanished,
they immediately began an investigation into
the exact ‘how’s and ‘why’s, the answers
to what exactly had happened here.
After all, while not a huge place, Darrington
was home to nearly a thousand residents, and
that many people don’t just disappear.
If they even had disappeared and weren’t
just… dormant.
But what the Foundation uncovered was a gruesome
discovery, that led to them not only demolishing
the entire North Carolinian town, but purchasing
all the land around it to keep the area under
permanent observation.
Prior to demolition, however, the Ministry
of Sevenfold Blessing had been one of the
oldest buildings in Darrington, much like
most town churches.
And it was while searching the offices of
this church that Foundation clean-up crews
discovered their first piece of evidence,
the initial clue about what had happened to
this deserted town.
They recovered a series of cassette tapes,
each with a recording of sermons that had
been given within the Ministry of Sevenfold
Blessing.
These were all delivered by one Pastor Bartholomew
Jenner, the first having been recorded on
August 17th of 1959, two years earlier.
“My friends, I want to talk to you about
the Bible offers, tonight,” Pastor Jenner
began in the first of these recordings.
“I want to talk to you about what you are
owed.
I want to talk to you about…
I want to talk to those of you who are struggling,
right now.
To those of you who have hardship and pain.
Maybe you’ve heard that the Bible only nourishes
the spirit; that God provides only for our
immortal souls.
Well, my friends, I am here to tell you that
this is simply not true.”
Pastor Bartholomew Jenner seemed to be focused
on the discussion of very real, relatable
problems.
After all, what person hasn’t felt unsatisfied
with their life at one point or another?
And this was apparently no different for the
people of Darrington.
“Many of you can think of places in your
lives where you have not yet risen.
Where you are not yet victorious.
Marriage.
Finances.
Health.
But do not fret, my friends.
God wants you to rise.
He has cleared the path for you.
It is one littered with His earthly treasures;
to claim them, you need only to shed your
old selves and be reborn.”
The pastor was merely using the shared faith
of the township to help reaffirm that their
struggles were not the be all and end all
of their lives.
Or at least, that’s how it first appeared.
But the religious practices taking place in
this first recording would soon take a bizarre
turn, making it clear there was something
far more sinister, even cult-like, going on
in the Ministry of Sevenfold Blessing.
“Now, if you would…
some of the ladies from the mayor's office
were kind enough to collect these cicada shells.
Pass them along.
Each of you take one – yes, the children
too.
Be careful.
Very careful.
They are fragile.
Each of you, take one, and hold it in your
left hand.
Yes.
The left hand, not the right.
Your left.”
The shells of dead cicadas hardly seemed like
common fare for a sermon like this.
Although, as the recording continued, it was
easy to understand that Pastor Jenner intended
these discarded insect carapaces to be something
of a metaphor, even if they were pretty gross
– especially to some of the younger members
of his congregation.
He explained to the Darrington residents that
these cicada shells were meant to be symbolic
of whatever hardship the citizens were currently
struggling with in their lives; whether it
was work, a marriage, or an ill family member.
Then came the next part of this unorthodox
practice; the pastor instructed everyone in
the congregation to picture themselves holding
their biggest problem in their left hand…
“Now, I want you to squeeze your left hand.
Squeeze it into a fist.
Feel that problem cracking; like old, dried
out paper.
Feel it crumble to dust,” Jenner told them,
and the residents of Darrington did so, crushing
their cicada shells until there was nothing
left.
“Everyone, open your eyes.
Don't you feel better?
Stronger?
This is what is offered.
Our hardships are like the shell; we shall
cast them aside even as they crumble.
God has cleared a path.”
Needless to say, the Foundation agents that
recovered the tapes of Pastor Jenner’s odd
sermons weren’t entirely sure what to make
of them.
And as unusual as they were, the recordings
did little to indicate where the townspeople
of Darrington, North Carolina, had disappeared
to.
But as they listened further, what they found
was even more unsettling than an entire congregation
of people crushing cicada shells.
In the second recording, dated December 19th
of 1959, Pastor Jenner was once again presiding
over his congregation.
He had just finished quoting a passage from
Matthew, chapter twenty-five, verse thirty,
which related to a Biblical tale known as
the Parable of the Talents.
In this story, a master puts his servants
in charge of a differently sized portion of
his wealth while he is away, then judges them
based on whether or not his servants make
a profit using his money.
The third servant, who had received the least
talents – meaning an amount of money – was
punished for burying his share in the ground;
“cast into the outer darkness” to face
“weeping and gnashing of teeth.”
It was after making mention of this unprofitable
servant that Pastor Jenner went on to address
even more of the bizarre, almost ritualistic,
practices he had been introducing to his sermons.
“Now, some of you have expressed concerns
over the new sacraments.
A few have even called them sacrilege.
And yet, have we not prospered?
Have these same nay-sayers, these same ‘Doubting
Thomases’ not profited from our good works?”
the pastor declared.
“I have shown you how to heal the sick with
the Lord’s Prayer and the blood of an unbaptized
child.
I have shown you how to see your future in
the steaming entrails of a quivering crow.
I have shown you the path to glory.
But I cannot make you follow this path.
I can only show it to you; it is you and you
alone who must follow it – who must rise
and shed your old self.”
Shed your old self.
The words immediately called to mind the image
of the cicadas, insects that discard their
outer carapaces and emerge anew.
Bugs that also burrow into the ground and
wait, lying dormant under the earth for years
at a time.
All before they emerge, rising up again…
so they can spread.
It was becoming clear that Pastor Jenner was
certainly deviating further and further from
the church’s normal religious practices.
His bold and blatant descriptions of what
sounded like ritualistic sacrifices were shocking
enough to hear; speaking of using blood and
entrails to bring the town the prosperity
it sought.
But if that wasn’t bad enough, the worst
was still yet to come… contained within
the third and final recording.
Unlike the previous cassettes, most of the
sermon from June 7th 1960 was almost completely
unintelligible.
And without any visual evidence to go with
it, it was hard for the Foundation to make
out exactly what was going on.
It began with another quote from Matthew,
this time chapter twenty-eight, verse six;
which made mention of the resurrection of
Jesus, that he had risen, and that people
should come and see where the Lord lay.
“Not a metaphor, my friends,” Pastor Jenner
explained, before urging his congregation
to join in some kind of formation.
“Step forward.
Mothers behind their daughters, fathers behind
their sons.
Turn to face the…”
The recording became unintelligible again
after that point, with only a few more words
being audible.
The pastor seemed to have gathered the townsfolk
of Darrington, presumably for some new form
of ritual.
He encouraged the town’s children to close
their eyes and pray, before reminding the
congregation that God sacrificed the life
of his only son, Jesus.
Frighteningly, it appeared that Pastor Jenner
was implying the adults of Darrington should
do the same.
One of the next fragments of his sermon that
could be deciphered declared:
“…lamb is slaughtered to feed the lion.
The Son is slaughtered to feed…”
Between more and more noise interfering with
the recording, Pastor Jenner could be heard
saying:
“The pact is complete.
This world shall be our paradise.”
Before encouraging his congregation – or
those who were left – to dig deep and wait.
Then came perhaps the most horrific part of
the tape.
The remainder of the recording lasted thirty
minutes, comprised of pure static.
Or, the Foundation agents listening to it
assumed, at first, that it was just interference.
But further audio analysis seemed to suggest
that the long, continuous mass of hissing
wasn’t static at all; it was the chittering
sound of insects…
like the noise made by cicadas.
For a time, the incident at Darrington left
the Foundation baffled.
There seemed to be no clear answer as to what
had happened.
Not one of the town’s residents was anywhere
to be found, and on top of that, there were
no bodies.
No remains of any kind to speak of; if they
were dead, there would at least be some kind
of trace.
And then there were all the questions raised
by Pastor Bartholomew Jenner’s strange sermons;
why did he seem so focused on enacting rituals?
Did any of his methods really benefit the
town?
And why did he place so much emphasis on…
cicadas, of all things?
Answers were few and far between, although
almost six decades after the Foundation discovered
the desolate town of Darrington, a new development
would come to light…
To be more accurate, it was fifty-six years
later.
On the 11th January 2017, a Foundation agent
named Daniel Mitchell was patrolling the area
that had formerly been Darrington, North Carolina
– before the Foundation had demolished all
traces of the town.
By this point, the SCP Foundation had long
thought that they had figured out exactly
what SCP-3089 was; they had even encountered
it emerging in a number of different forms
in both 2007 and 2015.
However, it was what Daniel Mitchell happened
across during the routine monthly patrol that
revealed the horrifying truth.
At the outskirts of the area where the town
had once been, a series of sinkholes had opened
up, at some point between the previous monthly
check and this one in early 2017.
And if you think that these sinkholes caused
a disturbance in the earth and uncovered all
the bodies of the former residents or Darrington,
you’d be wrong.
It was far, far stranger…
The Foundation conducted a full-scale examination
of the sinkholes around the demolished North
Carolinian town.
And these weren’t just a few patches of
loose ground that had sunk through.
The geological survey the Foundation carried
out quickly revealed that these sinkholes
led to an extensive network of tunnels deep
underground.
They extended several hundred kilometers outwards,
practically covering the entire underside
of where Darrington had been.
The tunnels seemed far too big than any other
created by any natural means, but the entire
network also appeared too rudimentary, too
imperfect to have been carved using any modern
excavation technology like a large drill.
Plus, if equipment like that had been on site,
the Foundation would have noticed, as they
kept the area monitored.
It was almost like something had been burrowing
through the ground, only to eventually crawl
back up to the surface, resulting in the sinkholes.
What’s more, the Foundation’s geological
tests suggested that the network of tunnels
was almost four whole decades old.
That would have placed the date of their creation
about ten years after the disappearances of
everyone in Darrington.
Naturally, the Foundation immediately launched
a mission to explore more of the tunnels.
Before even completing a full sweep of the
underground space in its entirety, they had
made another discovery.
Contained within the tunnels was over a whole
ton of organic material that had been mostly
preserved without decomposing too much.
The SCP Foundation began gathering samples
for testing, finding most of this material
to be severely desiccated dermis tissue.
That’s the dense layer of skin beneath the
epidermis, and it had all been entirely dried
out.
But that wasn’t all the testing uncovered.
According to genetic analysis, the tissue
had two distinct types of DNA present.
The first being easily identified as human
genetic material, which made sense.
Despite the material lacking in moisture,
the dermis tissue didn’t match the skin
of any other mammal.
But then there was the other DNA present.
Combined with the expected human DNA was the
presence of something else that the Foundation
researchers had quite some difficulty finding
a match for.
Eventually, they determined that this genetic
material entangled with human DNA belonged
to the Cicadtta montana… better known as
the New Forest cicada.
Cicadas again.
Cicada DNA mixed with human DNA, discovered
in a large network of underground tunnels.
All beneath the same town where a pastor had
his congregation crush cicada shells in their
left hands during one of his sermons.
Ten years before the sinkhole incident, the
Foundation was alerted to a particular YouTube
channel by the name of ‘Kai Sanchez: Positively
Rich’.
On the surface, Kai was one of many online
grifters, preaching about how easy it was
to quickly achieve an obscene amount of wealth
by simply believing in yourself.
Usually, if not always, these types of people
were trying to scam their audience of loyal
subscribers into investing in some kind of
illicit moneymaking scheme or any number of
other cons; promising their followers easy
money that never came.
But Kai Sanchez’s channel was slightly different.
So much so that the Foundation had to contain
his entire audience, deeming them to have
been affected by SCP-3089.
The video that caught the Foundation’s attention
was an hour-long upload from Kai titled ‘Seven
Secrets to Ascend the Ladder of Prosperity’.
There was that word again – prosperity – the
same thing Pastor Jenner had promised his
congregation in Darrington.
And the similarities didn’t end there.
In his video, much like the pastor during
his sermons, Kai Sanchez encouraged his audience
to visualize their success in order to achieve
it.
He implied that the human consciousness could
impact reality; for example, if his viewers
just imagined themselves having a bigger bank
account or looking more attractive, then these
things would manifest themselves in the real
world.
One of Kai’s ‘Secrets to Ascend the Ladder
of Prosperity’ was as follows: “Visualize
your ascendance.
Re-imagine yourself as someone who can reach
the top of that ladder.
Shed your old identity.
Tear it off and throw it aside – like dead
skin.
You won't need it.
Not where you're going.”
The resemblance to Pastor Jenner’s sermons
was uncanny.
Kai’s video even encouraged that his audience
leave scraps out to lure stray cats into their
homes, and then, once they had one, to take
a knife and… well, you remember what happened
in Darrington.
But Kai Sanchez made sure to specify: “Remember
to hold the knife with your left hand…”
Another online community was tagged by the
Foundation for similar teachings.
This group of insular men were trying to apply
the same methodology primarily to attract
women.
However, they also reasoned it could be used
to improve their own financial status and
physical stature; all done through visualizing
and believing that doing so would make these
things improve.
That having faith would grant them prosperity.
This disturbed community even tried to use
bug-rattlers to emit frequencies to aid in
attracting women.
Contained within these rattlers were the preserved
remains of… cicadas.
Male cicadas have tymbals, structures on their
outer shell that emit a loud hissing, chittering
noise that they often use to find a mate,
after spending so much time dormant underground…
before burrowing up to the surface.
And if you’ve been paying attention, you
might be able to guess exactly where this
is going…
SCP-3089 is a phenomenon that occurs within
communities of people who are seeking some
form of prosperity.
Whether that community be a town, a group
of like-minded people online, or any other
group of collected individuals.
The particular type of prosperity these people
are all seeking can be anything; from spiritual
enlightenment, to financial success.
The SCP Foundation doesn’t yet quite understand
exactly how SCP-3089 starts, only that communities
affected by it will attempt to achieve their
chosen material success through the application
of rituals, like visualizing what they hope
to overcome and achieve, and practicing sacrifices.
In short, these people have to believe these
acts will grant them what they want.
They need to be willing to go far enough to
do unspeakable things.
They need to have faith.
Although what they don’t realize is, some
things can feed on that faith, they can harvest
it…
Before these communities realize the terrible
things that they have done – or who exactly
has tricked them into performing these rituals
– they’ll begin to undergo a horrific
transformation process; known as SCP-3089-B.
It begins in the chrysalis stage.
Members of a community that has been affected
by SCP-3089 will experience a declined state
of metabolism.
Now classified as instances of SCP-3089-A,
their brain activity, heart rate, and body
temperature will all begin to lower.
Over a period of between three and six hours,
these people will then suffer a change to
their epidermis – the outer layer of skin.
It starts to harden, until it has formed a
dense, brittle substance…
like a shell.
Next comes the second stage of SCP-3089-B:
metamorphosis.
Internally, SCP-3089-A individuals will develop
a number of teratomas – a type of germ cell
tumor that can contain several different types
of tissue, such as hair, muscle, and bone.
During the next two or three weeks, these
tumors will expand and dissolve the person’s
soft tissue.
Then there’s the final stage: emergence.
An instance of SCP-3089-A will exit its dormant
state that began in the initial stage.
Once they have awoken, then… something exits
the outer epidermal shell.
It will not communicate.
Some will retain remnants of internal organs
– such as eyes or lungs – however, these
are vestigial, no longer serving any purpose.
The brain functions deviate from any normal
human patterns.
Having completed the process, this… thing
will attempt to burrow down into the soil
via any means at its disposal.
An outer shell.
Digging into the soil.
The tunnels underneath Darrington.
The genetic material uncovered below.
Dermis tissue with two types of DNA.
A mix of human … and cicada.
There is something out there.
It is preying on people’s faith, their longing
for prosperity.
Then, when these communities are presented
with someone who can take advantage of that
faith – like Pastor Jenner or Kai Sanchez
– they find themselves encouraged to push
their faith to its furthest limit.
And then, they’re rewarded by becoming something
else…
something nightmarish.
The question is: when they wake up, and crawl
back out from their tunnels, leaving a sinkhole
in their wake… where do these cicada creatures
go?
The anomalous religions that the SCP Foundation
has cataloged and studied over the years are
many in number and bottomless in depth, with
specialized para-theological researchers limiting
themselves to just one or maybe two faiths,
diving fully into a religion of their choice
and mastering its forbidden knowledge.
But the Foundation is careful to make sure
that those researching these faiths don’t
succumb to their beliefs, as many anomalous
religions are dangerous to the organization
in practice, involving tasks such as making
blood pacts with ancient gods, or modifying
one’s body to better suit a divine purpose.
There’s some seriously nasty stuff involved
in the immaterial world, almost to the point
where it makes you wonder why anyone would
be suckered into joining up with what appears
to be from the outside, just another cult
of crazies.
But let’s not generalize.
Religions, even those that are non-anomalous,
are all strange from the outside, even if
one may seem natural to you.
But one anomalous religion stands out from
all the rest as having more active followers,
more history, and more documented culture
than any other, and that is Sarkicism.
Hold on to your flesh, because today on SCP
Explained, we’re going to be answering the
question “What is Sarkicism?”, and hopefully
don’t get distracted and ritually sacrifice
you, the viewer, in the name of the Grand
Karcist Ion along the way.
Let’s get to it, meatbags.
Before we begin, it’s important to note
that Sarkicism is an incredibly dense and
deep religion, and that covering every last
detail of it in a short period of time would
be a herculean, nigh-impossible task for even
the most well-read Sarkic lore-masters.
So where would you even start?
What is Sarkicism?
To best understand that, we’re going to
bring you back all the way to the beginning
of human history, to the ancient world of
the Eurasian continent, where sprawling empires
ruled and war between them was an all-too-common
occurrence.
In what is now south-central Siberia, the
Daevite Empire ruled with an iron fist.
The Daeva were a warrior culture, with militarism,
conquest, gruesome human sacrifice, and thaumaturgic,
magic rituals being universally consistent
in their culture, according to the few historical
accounts available that make mention of the
empire.
The Daevites practiced anomalous magic, arcane
rituals, and sacrifices that bolstered their
power, longevity, and standing within their
society.
The empire was ruled by a theocratic aristocracy
called the daeva, those who were especially
attuned to the anomalous world, who practiced
cannibalism and thaumaturgy, and whose bodies
were so warped and modified by decades of
magic alteration that Foundation historians
would come to the conclusion that the Daeva
were so divergent from modern humans that
they could be considered a separate species
altogether.
But how the Daeva relate to Sarkicism remains
the question.
And the answer is found in the Empire’s
slave-owning culture.
The Daevites owned many, many slaves.
People they had bought or taken from their
lands as a sign of pure Daevite power in the
form of ownership over another human being.
Daevite city states had massive, sprawling
slave populations, and among those, was a
young boy by the name of Ion.
Ion’s appearance would be depicted over
the years by Sarkic art and culture as inconclusive
and varied, whether it was their gender, or
even the question of whether or not Ion resembled
a human, the cult of personality that would
crop up around Ion would be a testament to
Sarkicism’s eventual widespread culture,
but it was here, in ancient western Siberia,
where those seeds of Sarkicism originated.
According to the most prominent Sarkic texts,
Ion was a slave, like many others in the Daevite
empire.
Born into slavery by a Daevite mother and
a concubine father, the circumstances of Ion’s
birth indicate that he was destined to be
a slave from the onset.
But there was something remarkable about them.
Ion, in the eyes of his masters, was different
from other slaves.
He was intelligent, and so much so that the
decision was made for Ion to serve under a
Daevite priestess, where he could hone his
skills to serve the empire in ways unlike
the other slaves, who toiled away constructing
massive public works or died in foreign lands
on the field of battle.
Ion did not understand what differentiated
him from others, and why he deserved such
special treatment, but it was the realization
that the only thing separating him from his
masters was the possession of power that would
serve as the basis for Sarkicisms founding
doctrines.
Ion watched in horror as those they knew succumbed
to the backbreaking work that the empire forced
upon its slaves, and how prevalent death and
destruction were among its people.
Inside Ion grew a great rage for the Daevites,
who flaunted their power over others in the
form of slavery.
He wished to transcend the physical limitations
that kept him and his fellow slaves in bondage
and service to the Daevites.
Ion knew that their masters practiced thaumaturgy,
a form of magic that granted great power to
its users, and in a brutal world where power
is what defines who is master and who is slave,
the prospects of achieving it became more
important to Ion than anything else.
If he could harness such power for himself,
Ion could break free from the chains of slavery
that kept him subservient to those Daevite
masters.
He would achieve apotheosis, the belief that
an individual could ascend to godhood through
raw power and unbridled will.
Over time, Ion's hatred of the so-called “living
gods” of the Daeva grew so strong that he
actively began plotting their downfall.
Around 1800 BCE, Ion’s influence among the
lowest ranks of the empire was inescapable.
He was charismatic, he was a slave, he was
powerful, and he spoke of violence.
Of seizing Daevite magic for himself and using
it to elevate himself into power.
Ion’s tenets and beliefs appealed to the
slave population, who also grew hungry for
freedom.
Ion’s creed spread like wildfire, and would
form the basis for all Sarkic belief in the
centuries that came.
First, there was apotheosis, which Ion was
striving to achieve, and the path to doing
so was the will to power.
The next belief covered that concept in depth.
Ion believed that the will to power was the
primary driving force of man, as an individual
seeks to master all things within its domain,
they exert that power onto others, and others
have the ability to exert it back in opposition.
Desire is the measure of power, and those
with a stronger will always triumph over the
weak.
The next belief was the act of Theophagy,
a hypothetical tenant that Ion was toying
with after observing the Daevite religion
for years.
Theophagy referred to the act of sacrificial
consumption of a god, and upon eating them
achieving thaumaturgical, reality-bending,
and all-powerful abilities.
There were many gods in the universe, and
this Ion knew, but none of them were fit for
him to worship.
Instead, he would crave their power.
As a metaphorical example of theophagy, Ion
wanted nothing more than to consume the Daevite
empire whole, taking its power for his own.
Next, there was the idea of sacrifice.
Whether it was for the sacrifice of the self
for the benefit of many, or sacrifice of many
for the benefit of the individual, Ion believed,
much like his masters, that ritual sacrifice
was a powerful tool that could be used as
a means to achieve an end.
Those who commanded the sacrifice were showing
their power, bringing them that much closer
to apotheosis.
Those who were sacrificed were experiencing
strife, which would only make them stronger
than before.
Muscles suffer damage, but eventually heal.
The mind develops toleration against hardship,
such as slavery.
This cycle of destruction and regeneration
in strife was, according to Ion, one of the
greatest tutors in the natural world.
Ion’s final core belief would become the
most prominent, outward facing indicator of
Sarkicism, and that was the idea of “shepherding
the flesh”.
Ion believed that all living things descended
from a single progenitor, an all-powerful
god known as Yaldabaoth, who the Sarkics would
later regard as the principal power in the
universe.
Yaldabaoth’s relationship with Sarkicism
is tenuous at best, with modern Sarkic cults
either admiring or fearing the enemy.
One thing is certain though, Yaldabaoth remains
present in all Sarkic culture, even if the
religion doesn’t exactly worship the god
itself.
Yaldabaoth was a destroyer, who fed upon gods,
worlds, and stars, who incidentally created
the entire universe and life itself as a result
of its power-hungry actions.
The creation stories talk of Yaldabaoth as
a blind entity, driven solely by instinct,
fueled by the forces of primordial chaos.
As life was created as a result of Yaldabaoth’s
existence, it was ultimately unguided by intelligence,
and its spread throughout the universe was
similar to that of a germ than anything grand
or divine.
Ion, upon learning of these myths, came to
the conclusion that the multiverse itself
was only an altar that held life’s existence,
which was brought into reality for the ultimate
sacrifice at the hands of Yaldabaoth.
The entity would one day reclaim all of existence
for itself, harvesting what it created and
consuming it whole, as this was Yaldabaoth’s
nature and purpose as the ultimate being of
the cosmos.
Ion saw this shared ancestry among life as
the key to genetic modification.
As all life was derived from Yaldabaoth, it
held a similar genetic code, and it would
become the Sarkic right to guide and cultivate
organic matter, stealing the genes of other
lifeforms or creating entirely new ones.
Through this perversion of life, Ion felt
he could ascend from something ordinary to
a living god, fueled by the unending cycle
of sacrifice and creation.
With his radical, power-hungry beliefs rapidly
spreading throughout the Daevite empire, mostly
among its slaves, the leading Daeva became
fearful of Ion.
Attempts to assassinate him or usurp Ion’s
influence were met with failure, and only
fueled the mission of his followers, furthering
the belief that if they were to achieve godhood,
they had to overthrow the Daevites, who were
the most present, all-powerful beings in their
lives.
This all came to a head when Ion launched
his final act against the Daevite empire.
After years of sowing the seeds of disharmony
and hate among the slave population, Ion rallied
his followers and swept them up into a full-scale
rebellion.
In a short time, Ion overthrew the province
he grew up in, fueled by the rage of his followers,
who mercilessly razed the city and slaughtered
the Daevites like animals.
Those who were present could see the inspiration
Ion brought to his followers, how he commanded
them as if he were a living god.
How he used the reality-bending magic of the
Daeva and turned it against them, with his
followers utilizing anomalous warfare in a
horrific, gruesome way.
Flesh was turned into a weapon, living beings
were contorted and transformed into monstrosities
and abominations that fueled the Sarkic war
machine.
Daeva thaumaturgy simply could not compete
against the permeating, powerful, and unrestricted
abilities of Ion’s followers.
Before long, the city fell before the being
who had, in that moment of bloodlust and fury,
achieved apotheosis.
The being who was now known as the Grand Karcist
Ion.
The Grand Karcist and his followers rampaged
throughout the ancient world, felling cities
and entire empires to serve as stepping stones
in their path to godhood.
Their weapons and armor were unlike anything
else at the time, and their utilization of
powerful, flesh-bending magic made them unstoppable
on the field of battle.
The city of Adytum was established as the
Sarkic holy city, where Ion ruled as the Sorcerer-King
as a living deity.
Texts from this period suggest that Ion had
somehow usurped control of Yaldabaoth the
Devourer itself, wearing the flesh of the
Old God as a sort of armor, and crafting a
kingdom from its body.
While this depiction is most likely only a
metaphor for how much Ion resembled Yaldabaoth
in philosophy and pure power, the image of
a living god devouring and succeeding the
old one is a striking visual that surely empowered
many Sarkics at the time.
Another story from Sarkic mythology during
this period is “The Six Ordeals of Ion”,
a parable that told of six challenges that
were issued to Ion by the Archons, the servants
of Yaldabaoth, who challenged the newly crowned
king of Adytum.
By enduring their trials, Ion mastered the
rituals, practices, and beliefs ubiquitous
to Sarkicism and broke free from the bondage
of mortal limitations.
But the authenticity of this myth is debated,
and the nature of the ordeals and Ion’s
further relationship with Yaldabaoth remains
unknown.
But why did the Grand Karcist Ion, with his
flowing red robes and wielding his all-powerful
staff, who twisted flesh and drew blood when
he so much as drew breath, fall into such
obscurity that his religion remains a mysterious
and obscure footnote in the Foundation’s
archives?
If the Sarkics were as powerful as these early
texts state, where are they today?
Why did the horrific city of Adytum, built
of living, organic material that stood monument
to Ion’s indomitable will, fall?
In Sarkicism’s golden age, from 1600 and
1200 BCE, the religion’s permeation was
inescapable.
Like the diseases they wielded in their wars,
Sarkicism spread like a contagion across the
world.
Everywhere they went, they assimilated tribes
and villages into their ranks, fighting under
the banner of Adytum and the Sarkic faith.
This expanded empire would be referred to
as Kalmaktama, or the “Deathless”.
Many tried to defeat these brutal invaders,
including the king of the Hittite empire himself,
but all fell before them.
As the Kalmaktama Empire attempted to establish
a foothold in the Mediterranean, invading
and colonizing the islands of Cyprus, Crete,
and Gyaros, for the first time in Sarkic history,
the tides of war began to turn against the
religion.
A coalition of kingdoms was formed in response
to the Sarkic threat, created by the Egyptians,
Greeks, Minoans, Canaanites, Assyrians, and
most importantly, the Mekhanites, who were
the followers of the Church of the Broken
God.
The cult of Mekhane, the Broken God, had urged
these kingdoms to unite against the Sarkic
threat, and now united, outfitted their allies
with superior, Mekhanite technology that anomalously
enhanced the empires’ war capabilities,
putting them on-par with the Sarkic death-sorcerers.
And so, a great war was waged between the
Kalmaktama Empire and the Coalition of Kingdoms.
The details of such are largely lost to time,
but the war itself was fought with the full
power of the Sarkics and the Mekhanites clashing
with one another, and its consequences left
an imprint on the earth itself.
A death toll that estimates place at 20 to
30 million, mass graves, anomalous weapons,
and even the deployment of giant, mechanical
beings created by the Mekhanites known as
“Colossi” that rampaged through Sarkic
settlements and cities.
Though the battle was costly on both sides,
the Kalmaktama Empire fell to the Coalition,
and the once impenetrable city of Adytum was
destroyed, forever.
Sarkicism would fall into obscurity, and the
empire would be forgotten, possibly because
it was much easier than remembering the horrors
Ion subjected the world to.
The Grand Karcist himself disappeared, his
whereabouts unknown shortly after the fall
of Adytum.
Some said he had ascended into godhood, leaving
the world behind.
Others said he was slain in battle, nothing
more than a man who believed he would never
die.
The Sarkic religion was effectively extinguished
from the world, never to be seen again.
Or so, that’s what the coalition was led
to believe.
Though the empire and Adytum fell, and Ion
disappeared, an idea as tantalizing and powerful
as Sarkicism is difficult to snuff out entirely.
In reality, Sarkicism would continue in secret,
in both its homeland in the Urals and among
the offshoot tribes that had fought under
Adytum’s banner.
These sects of Sarkicism would practice their
beliefs in their war-ravaged homeland, which
suffered a great collapse, resulting in the
fall of kingdoms, a crisis of refugees, and
a decline of art, literature, science, and
technology.
Lingering disease and famine from Sarkic biological
weapons spread even to the kingdoms of the
coalition, resulting in an event historians
refer to as the Late Bronze Age Collapse.
The empire that was once Deathless had now
fallen, but its followers remained, practicing
their power-craving rituals in secret and
without centralization.
This led to a Sarkic diaspora, where various
sects and Sarkic cults, each with culturally
distinct beliefs, would crop up throughout
the Eurasian continent.
While the Foundation is unsure of the specifics
of these cults’ activities and beliefs,
elements of Sarkicism would soon begin to
permeate the upper echelon of society.
Infiltrating Carpathian cults or sought out
by nobles themselves, who ignored the rumors
of devil worship and witchcraft to seek out
Sarkic power for their courts.
The tempting power that Sarkicism granted
made it a popular choice to be practiced in
secret by upper-ranking royals and even entire
noble families.
From their position of power, where they had
access to knowledge, influence, and a fresh
supply of sacrifices, Sarkicism endured.
Over time, this would result in the formation
of Sarkic “Great Houses”, where families
practiced their own interpretation of Sarkicism,
the religion that was now mutated into hundreds
upon hundreds of variations and subcultures.
These great houses would focus on individualism,
and applying their powers to fulfill their
self-serving needs.
Sarkicism, now decentralized completely, would
spread throughout Europe via marriage, as
a high society of cults and magicians whose
true motives for ruling their kingdoms and
provinces were kept hidden behind their meaty,
flesh-curtain of absolute secrecy.
Today, the Sarkic cults persist, and their
anomalies are frequently uncovered by the
Foundation.
Understanding them and their religion, however,
is another ordeal entirely, and the majority
of Sarkic history, culture, and practices
are unknown to the organization.
But they’re still out there.
In the highest ranks of urban society, in
the most remote villages of the world.
There will always be those who crave to wield
flesh.
The followers of Ion who hope to achieve Apotheosis,
however they may believe they can do so.
Though the details remain unclear, there is
one thing the Foundation has realized over
its years of studying the religion: Sarkicism
has, and always will, remain.